all right and we all love the last word
with law Cognito and I bought this
special Friday night campfire what's
good or T it is after hours and we got
an awesome guest in the house so we're
gonna talk about everything in the world
the destiny with a man who was a veteran
of the game been around on this thing
for a very long time but we're gonna see
if we can make him blush so back to you
sir
let's do it welcome to the last word
episode number 110 Vincent of gore is
Friday Friday night and we're back in
front of the can fire for some more
looters shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about a special guests so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a lord who was not only a
pleasure to interact with the non
testing community but always provides a
safe haven of chill vibes whether it be
his sick crucible gameplay clips or
attention to detail within the law
there's no question regard his passion
for the destiny franchise introducing
the Korean and host of the NEMS plays
YouTube and twitch channels the edge
Lord who always embraces the ways of the
void and my fellow warlock brethren who
always remains anti better guide enough
to make his debut at the campfire of the
last word mom made your name plays how
you doing sir more titles than I have in
destiny right now like to make you feel
welcome and welcome home we got the
after-hours campfire literally evening
campfire so it's actually the right time
of day
EMS appreciate you guys working around
my crazy schedule and like we were
talking about this before the show
started we've been trying to get this to
happen for so long yeah work yeah it was
like we've we've chatted way too much to
not make this happen so so absolutely
there so a lot of Destiny been going on
I've been seeing so just enjoy the
season so far
how we feeling what arrivals how we
feeling honestly a lot better than I did
with worthy
it's a low bar I'll be honest
way down here in the grass like I if I'm
being realistic I think within the first
week of season of arrivals I probably
played more than it played through like
the season of the word we're the
entirety thanks thanks yeah and like
don't get me wrong I'm not trying to
knock season or the worthy but I knew
that a big ticket item for that season
was gonna be trials yeah that's not my
demographic so I kind of just sat sat it
out played some PvP with friends for the
most part and that was really it gonna
say it noticed you got a nice little I
can't look at the title scream the same
way anymore thanks to nice little
shout-out recently so I wanted to start
there because I can't even look at the
game differently now from what you made
me look at from the music mm-hmm so
explain what I'm talking about for those
who don't know may not know on Twitter
what what did you what revelation came
to you recently so during one of the
runs of the new dungeon prophecy after
the second encounter which is the big
Cuba room you can find the emissary in
the wasteland and if you approach her
she'll have different lines of dialogue
either for you and for the people that
are in your party they'll help they'll
hear different things but I got an
interesting clip this past week where
drifter and heiress talk about and
drifter asks her if if she ever sang a
song to shacks and she of course
dismisses him she's like that could such
a stupid question come on really
yeah and it turns out that she didn't so
when she realizes it that he her he
obviously that Scheck maths must have
heard something she repeats the hum and
drifters like yeah that's the one and it
turns out that is a viral chant by Saba
Thune now here's where it gets I never
get interest at on this it gets
interesting so
in the previous season I want to say
what season of dawn I'm sure you guys
remember the devil's ruined one of my
favorite is more dialog quest between
three Titans of my man Osiris continue
to tighten you're gonna be familiar with
the fact that shacks sings a certain so
when you go back and you listen to that
he is singing in a very specific um
which is the same one that Eris talked
about our boy shacks is under some sort
of influenced by Omkara and Sava food
because the school that he has a pup of
up there that is Anaheim Cara's skull
yes yes very deep revelation because um
your Cuttino please go on and I was
gonna say but that particular song has
been in there much longer than the
season of of dawn mmm Sabbath oon song
has been there since shadow keeps launch
because it's the main menu fame yeah
that was crazy I was going through the
article and just like the P of eclipse
you had and then it's the menu screen I
was like are you are you kidding me
right now bike that was that was so made
of cheese or whatever I forget the lot
though there looks like well just the
tone is consistent all throughout those
I'm going if it if like and it honestly
Bungie is good about the long game so if
you're sitting there looking at the
title screen I'm like they playing this
crap for a year I was like big up they
got three more years playing out but
just play on that scene man long con
seriously you know what's funny because
like I so I was playing with shift
during that dungeon and when I heard
that particular line I'm like I know
I've heard that somewhere yep and I
started going back I went all the way
back to like taking Kings soundtracks
and so my because I'm like I'm like I
know I've heard that where the hell have
I heard that hum and I started going
through like some of the more like
recent events and like wait a minute
hold up
let's go it started I like I saw the
Osiris one first right and then I'm like
okay it's definitely that but I know
I've heard that that's a that's a song
somewhere and I brought up the the
soundtrack and I've this for sure enough
the first one is the shadow keep it it's
there it's boom right even the viral
chant that you cannot unhear mm-hmm it's
there though it was is it's amazing and
again you know wow try to tell people
you know I actually be appalled I
actually had gotten into it about the
devil's request when it first came out
cuz um I'll see you all once he gave me
that net he had an article first and you
know kind of I don't say trashing it but
just like yeah you know it's average
whatever and for me I had read an
article like you're why I love it and I
said because I love the dialogue between
characters we don't get enough of that
you know to see how they were interest
Lee Saints been going a long time and
stuff like that so their point you say
you know what you got it right I see
what you cover for because because a lot
of people were upset at that question
remember they were like oh the gun was
given away so easy mhm and I said you
guys are missing the point it's about
the Lord's about these conversations and
at the end Saint I had remember he all
Shaq sold the bet to say yeah the bet
was to sing the song and at first we
just we just thought it was goofy right
I was right yes some goofy thing he's
got to do we all laughed at Shaq's for
jumping out of character is the you know
the normal tough-guy tight and have to
deceive yourself so okay boom and then
now again I do prophecy this weekend
it's all ties in because I literally did
prophecy shout out to Josh ran to his
name I gotta clear cuz he definitely got
the the prophecy dungeon done I was
called him out but he's forgiven so
anyway so we got we got it done and I
was in that part in the desert and I
remember and I'm just like holy and then
you see that conversation between eros
in the drift and she's like dark relics
are awakening around the whole system
that's never doing is using and I also
heard some stuff I shot the vibe it's
one of the law pieces that specifically
where but basically it was to the effect
like um he's been targeted
shacks has been targeted by Sabbath or
and the vibe is that you know he still
has some issues there's some darkness in
him like there's some things going on
with him so she's selecting certain
targets and I'm also curious about this
in conjunction with all the eyes that
we're seeing on all the planets you know
I don't know I'm assuming those are like
her watching in using those you know so
it's it's cool man I like where this is
going I love storytelling like this
subtle clues it's for them have you
noticed the placements of the eyes
though
yes did you notice what summer could be
right in that lost sector you know what
you call it it seems like every planet
that seems to be going is uh oh yeah
it's it's an eye there mmm I noticed
that I'm I'm very intrigued how they're
going to do that lore wise how they're
gonna remove those yeah yeah how they're
gonna remove those planets because so I
I haven't looked into it too too much
because I tend to like avoid spoilers
now that I kind of took a step back from
like the creating and the news and stuff
like that but I have heard that there is
a pretty a pretty interesting quest down
the down the line that involves involves
all those planets yeah we had jerk on a
couple weeks ago and we talked briefly
about just the idea of I'm gonna say one
word related to it and this isn't that
much of a spoiler hopefully but if you
want to avoid it shut your ears for like
five seconds the word evacuation yes and
that's the big one that everybody seems
to wonder because you have you know NPCs
on these planets that if the planets
going away hopefully there's some lures
to how these NPCs hopefully survive
whatever happens these planets maybe
they maybe they bail maybe they don't
and then you've got finally at least we
actually saw the update today in-game we
are going to tighten with the contact to
a public event next week I was waiting
on that one because yeah it's a 15-week
season which is long generally even for
them but if it was gonna be three weeks
because we've got IO
Titan still gotta get through Mars
mercury and the Leviathan otherwise I
may just like drive away I don't know
what's gonna happen they're still
curious how that one's getting handle
cuz that's its thing in itself but we
have four plane
and it was like if it's four weeks /
it'll fit I guess still so I was curious
how they were gonna time it and we know
Titans coming but we haven't seen
another pyramid ship come on yet so I
can't wait to see what the one on Titan
from the trailer just stare and square
at it looks really really cool
Daleks intimidating yeah it's just just
like staring right here down the barrel
of a gun basically it's kind of its
intimidating is the right word because
it's huge in that part is whether the
pyramid that's currently on IO itself if
that one is going to move to Titan or if
it's another one that is gonna enter the
atmosphere what would you prefer I would
prefer having another one coming because
I mean we saw the fleet that was
basically being teased all throughout
seaworthy 50s there's a lot of ships oh
yeah 50 plus by the time we were all
done don't pull it up I want them pull
it up on every planet yeah yeah I was
like there was 50 I think you guys can
find 4 to park around here mm-hmm
right yeah yes that's a lot of ships
dude stark is asking have you talked
about wanting to live on the pyramid yet
is this a big name it's dark you know
you were too so shut up because is it
just the fact that is a triangle so
edges are everywhere or let's go I'm
just gonna shake my fist @p no cuz he's
the one who started that so what's the
science why these parapet living baby
what's what's going on break it down so
I've always had like this one of an
alliance system between destiny and we
kind of got a tease of it with with see
the season of the drifter with the
Alliance yes the Lions quest and so the
fact that we now are kind of more
leaning towards using that particular
power it would be cool to see almost
like a split between the Vanguard you
know choosing to like stay away from it
and then guardians who are actually yo
that's dope
hand it over so you know I fell into
that particular side you know because
like if you know if there was ever like
a split like that to have a hub like a
social hub within like one of those
pyramids I mean we have one on the moon
mm-hmm you know so it is interesting I
get the other question from the audience
does the pyramid ship have a food court
[Laughter]
we got NIMS crew in chat we got a spread
out there I would I would hope so would
for Dvorak's you're dying yeah you got
vex milk is your beverage of choice
taking butter oh yeah all those things
are coming out there so yes question I'd
ask he just was like Oh from the
beginning like why destiny like why we
always tend a salata to guess like what
was the attraction and make you say yo
I'm in love with this game I want to
commit to this game fun fact there
wasn't initially movie to be you share
this file interesting yeah again so my
good buddy
Ashton him and I we used to work
together and he's a big Bungie guy he
loved all the Halos and he grew up with
them and I believe his dad actually also
edited I think halo twos documentaries
it was like a big deal for him so he was
looking forward towards destiny and at
the time pretty much the game that I
played it like almost as much as I
played destiny now was used to be call
of duty so I come from like you know
like mana warfare Teen Wolf it oh yeah
yeah and all that Golden Arrow right did
I spent some ungodly amount of time in
black ops 1 & 2 oh yeah
[Music]
and well you know he was like super into
the game and the night that the game
launched I'm never gonna forget this
this story because I was just kind of
like it was how it started
I was clocking in to work and he was
clocking out and he was like what are
you doing after work I'm like proud
Singh just gonna go home and chill he's
like alright well you're not anymore
you're gonna come with me
GameStop resume the midnight release for
destiny 1 they're gonna have food then
they're gonna have like handouts and
stuff like that so we can hang out there
I was like all right cool
mmm I had played the beta right but I I
wasn't it was like all right it was fun
but it was it to me it was just another
shooter I was like I don't know if I
want to commit to like another shooter
especially one with like abilities and
stuff like that I was just kind of like
its it was fun but it wasn't really like
my thing mmm
but that same that same night we were in
line because he got like the he got the
big addition and he was just like
looking at me as like people there taken
in and is like no you got to get it yeah
I was like I don't want to I need I need
someone to play with it I was like all
right all right I'll get it so we go in
I pay for the bass Edition I mean he was
like hit the season Oh like I don't even
know if I'm gonna like the meantime you
want me to buy the season pass and he's
like get it all right fine I got it and
the rest was history dude like I gotten
hooked mmm hooked immediately
hmm break it so ah so what it was just
the aesthetic the gig um play what what
specific give me some moments that you
like yo so this is it it was definitely
the it was the a lot of the original RPG
elements that aren't unfortunately
they're not in the game they kill trees
that we all men to kill trees dude I am
a sucker for being able to customize a
car
we lost the bill he said his connection
yeah you come back all right he did one
this one is nice income and we're
prepared for this he's banged back your
back all good yeah it's literally just
my internet your skill tree you could
take skill tree yeah so I love having
the ability to customize whenever
wherever and that's something that the
first one gave us you know that that was
pretty liberating fun fact I started off
as a hunter so did I actually I was
taken King it's been tightened since
when did you go warlock so what's that's
the question when did you go warlock
so I actually so I I started off with a
hunter and I remember I didn't even get
to like level 20 as the hunter then I
remember going into like the warlock
because I really I really liked seeing
my buddy ashen because he was he's been
a warlock since the beginning he he used
to be able to like just fly around and
like a time to do like difference like
spaces that I would have trouble getting
on yeah sounds like alright [ __ ] it i'm
i'm starting a warlock and we made it 20
minutes it's fine no you're good you're
good
okay so so yeah I created the warlock
and once I started getting like the
voidwalker stafa
I was like oh that's cool cuz like
you're you know if you remember being
able to customize it and back then you
could use bluem and annihilation in
conjunction yes and now it's kind of
separated so yes I was like holy crap
that's that's cool and then I saw that
like the blink was a thing yes
little fun fact about me I love x-men
I'm a big Marvel guy nice nice
yeah and Nightcrawler is one of my
favorite x-men back makes a lot more
sense yeah
warp Kings so yeah yeah Nightcrawler is
like one of my favorite characters and
so if you guys seen the x2 movie you
know where he teleports all over the
place um you know back in Indy one I was
like oh crap I can like blink and you
know do stuff like that so mmm I kind of
I kind of got hooked then and I did play
around with like other characters and I
maintained all three but I was always
better off with my warlock it's been
kind of like a progression as from like
destiny one to destiny to where I'm more
embraced for that warlock aspect and
then they introduced Nova warp oh and oh
that was it why you did that today
hunter in one of them clips you did he
was even yo he did see with this man it
was so disrespectful cuz I guess
somebody must have pissed you off and
the hunter I forgot what bad was it - I
did a Twilight guy I got and I didn't
even dope what you did was possible like
you were out in the area where you're
not supposed to be with a map tells you
get back into the game and you sitting
in teleporting in Nova warp super he's
shooting you did you get over to him and
it's like blue I say this is so
disrespectful of it I love it he had
been teabagging me the entire edge with
mountaintop and recluse oh god those
people and I have had it forever be my
favorite player alas again that's like
my favorite player I think that I've
ever made yes you're my Twitter if
anybody's curious yeah Twitter please
crystal if he ate all his Twitter you
gotta go see it is an audience the map
is twilight gap he's in over warp super
yeah I've got to comment you make it was
hilarious oh it was how to disrespect a
spectral blades hunter that had been tea
bagging you all game yes check that
you'll get delay put the link in the
chocolate early put the link in the chat
will be able to
the Twitter link the Twitter link might
work but that clip actually got on uh
Kotaku's highlight-reel
doing that's fire it was fire that's
what's up did we go in and then as far
as like the content creation like what
got you into one to be a content creator
um
bro man and Italian originally I used to
like tune into bromance stream Bremen
was the first one that I started
watching and it was more I got started
more towards with streaming I start
watching bro man and then started
walking to Thalian and I was like oh you
know this streaming thing looks pretty
fun so I got myself the the PlayStation
camera and kind of started off like that
it wasn't until rise of iron that picked
up steam a little bit um at the time it
was towards the end of rise of iron
before age of triumph okay um that I
remember sending an email to the at that
time brand manager for planet estimating
and I was like hey you know I know it's
slow but you know I have video equipment
I have streaming gear a decent
microphone if you guys are ever looking
for another creator or streamer like I
be super down to to help salute and sure
enough within a couple of weeks we we
started talking and they got me on to
Planet Destiny's a stream team nice so
that's how I kind of got that started so
as far as like um what what do you
prefer the most like as far as Cod that
you prefer streaming I know
schedule-wise was a bit tough but would
you eat a job or later yeah what what
aspects of concentration you enjoy
tables man there's there's ups to both
of them and there's downs to both of
them
I love the interactions with streaming
like that's that's a given you know
being able to talk to people and it to
me have always treated my streams as
Mars is a virtual couch first you know
just friends to hang out and talking and
you know just have a good time but the
informative side that YouTube creation
has that's intense man like that takes
some serious dedication that like once I
started doing that for PD I was able to
see it behind the curtain and like holy
[ __ ] it's enough it's fun it's fun but
it's really really hard cuz a lot of
people don't really consider that a 10
minute video can take someone about six
to seven hours to do yeah because you
got a you know at least from from like a
review perspective Errol you know you
probably won't have to play around with
different perks so you have to make sure
that you know what you're talking about
when it comes to using the perks in the
sandbox and PvE in PvP what works with
what what weapons you know like help it
shine what it doesn't and but you know
HS what process is the same it's in
insane and then figuring out you know
writing the script and then doing the
the voice-over recording the editing of
the voice getting all the clips together
putting it together
it's an insane process that takes so so
long and then the moment hits the
internet some dudes like oh well I'm
touched it better yeah it doesn't take
long for you to be like oh thanks for
taking me straight out at the knees
perfect here's the bad just finish it
off please I have so much respect yet
continue ya know so like that's that's
one of the aspects that like once I I
got into it I was like you just learn a
new level of respect for the people that
do this on a daily basis yes you know so
no I say you're absolutely right and
that's why I got so much respect for you
guys because I know I can't do it so for
me you know and I see the amount of you
know hours at a puts in and you guys put
in and like you said it's just just a 10
or a short clip there's so much work
involved behind it that most people
don't understand and I definitely could
resonate with the part about you know
the hit come you know captain comment in
your section to say whatever you know
come in there and rip something and he
ain't do he ain't do a bit of video
editing in his life but he he come you
know and and that's why I have so much
respect account sorry no no I grommets
who after him yeah I was like I mean you
spend I mean take any video like news I
used to do solo nightfall runs and that
was when you would get kicked to orbit
so it's like it took long enough just to
practice through it get a good run get a
feel of a comfort understand what to
explain and I would do live commentary
on mine which is a different ball of wax
versus a voiceover which is still its
own thing mmm
cuz it's like doing a good voice over is
like quality in itself but either way
your life so this idea is like it's
and then you'll get some that are like
hey thanks for the guide and then it
doesn't matter it's the first as soon as
you start getting just enough traction
you're like hey then you start getting
the consistent one or two down votes on
every way and you're like you're like
why that's like and I swear there's a
couple of people that just follow and
it's not even just me it's like anybody
it's like they just showed you just a
Down vote you and you're like just hate
it was like the amount of effort that
goes into this just to literally like
one of the first ones Oh new video down
put and it's just like yeah what's the
point
no I like to do is because this why I
like the guy that person wastes his time
out of his day like he giving me of you
know like I like that dude like you you
set your whole day towards this like
it's funny to be I think it's laughs
well thank you for thinking about me
metric button that was really fast I
appreciate that
crazy tough like I remember when not so
it's you that's definitely like one of
the main aspects to consider when it
comes to content creation but one thing
another thing that like you also have to
to like realize is competition
especially in a saturated field right
now um you know working with like with
planet destiny for for the time that I
was actively doing stuff with them you
know you have to see you have your
reaction time with topics that come out
have to be ungodly fast because you have
you have I don't even think this he's
human but you have hounded oh yeah off
that the dude like half an hour after
something is released the dude has the
information out there again fairly
certain he's not a human I don't believe
those are androids those living amongst
1% it's like you have to be on top of it
in lose one of the times that I remember
like really really feeling this was when
whisper of the worm first came out
because I was in charge of covering that
guide and showing you know basically how
to get
rounded and beat the encounter and and
all that stuff so I stayed I like I was
on that for about 12 hours trying to get
that all like on day one just working on
everything for that video to get it out
the following day it was its intense
dude it's really intense no you made
good point and that's the thing people
again people don't realize you said a
perfect sentence which is it is a
saturated field right so there is things
that you have to do to separate yourself
from others as well as if you do have
some information that's common it's got
to be kind of first right because it's
like accurate that's where people are
Russian so I get I got so much respect
for you guys because that's not easy
that's that's done and it's nothing more
demoralizing than then you know doing
all this work and then you know you know
it's already out there or you know
whatever or the information is incorrect
and you got to go back you know I kind
of think so definitely
got a huge respect man for you and
referencing that and stuff like that but
oh yeah man I wanted to pick your brain
on that and then Oh last question I got
free person for ya was um you are
considered like I consider you like the
anti medica right you will find things
and you will figure out a way to make
this work in the current sandbox when
everybody else has shifted towards you
know 600 autos and you are with the
graviton lives you know say you're out
there and I'm loving it so like I
actually share that but I want to know
why you do it why do you feel the need
to kind of go against the matter so
largely and honestly because if you put
a meta weapon in my hands it's just
garbage like that not in PvP yes but PvP
I'm garbage with it but continue to
bring it ya know yeah I mean I just
can't um I you give me I have what is
considered to be like a really really
really good spare rations that I got way
back in season of The Drifter mm-hm and
it's been Metis for a really long time
and I brought
have filled like maybe like two people
with it and it's just I don't know man
you if you you give Mindbenders to
someone out there they will somehow kill
you at like ten meters but if you give
me that same exact Mindbenders they just
killed me with I will somehow shoot
blanks that's like five feet away
oh I mean it just doesn't work for me
the one of mine there was a point where
I remember everybody wouldn't shut up
about trust
mmm and there was a point where that was
pretty popular I am I cannot stand that
gun you're like what's a lot of way
Navis to but it was just like 180 hand
cannons and me--don't mission people
like monstrous I got a good rest home
like I can't stand it I will use
anything happen anything but that had a
question from chat with the regards to
tractor cannon please clarify your
thoughts on said weapon hey you know
what this whole it was a crit buff I
think or Shiv I couldn't remember
sounds like rip sounds like a creep up
question or something no so he this is
probably when we were talking about
editing that is like one of like and I
can confidently 100% tell you that that
is like the worst video I've ever made
100% wise um why is that like the worst
video
that's a weird where is it so at that
time it was still a lot of pressure of
making stuff for planet destiny because
I kind of climbed up the ladder when it
comes to like the roles that I had in PD
you know started off as a streamer then
I was in the podcast a couple of times
and eventually became kind of like
a permanent member of the podcast and
then from the podcast I started doing
the YouTube stuff so I kind of like did
a little bit of everything with that so
the first couple of videos that I did
for PD uh for the YouTube section mmm it
was terrifying because plans that's me
at the time you know it was just kind of
fresh off the heels of the DCP crew
leaving so
that was very big shoes to fill I'm
special because you have people like
Holtzman and Taft and Breyer oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah so the pressure was was big
in that that video if you go look for it
it will show it just so that like the
voice narration and that it was just
probably like the worst one that I had
ever done and I remember emailing Ryan
after like it went up I'm like dude I
hate it can i redo it and he's like it's
it's already up it's it's fine just
leave it be nothing but ya know dude
it's so bad we're all our own worst
critic and I have never gone back I've
got mine too and it's like I can't tell
you how many times I'll go through and
either redo it or but I was like I don't
want to go back and look at some of my
old stuff I kind of scared what that
would be like so was that you're funnier
first you were saying when you went to
YouTube it was one of the very earlier
ones yeah so I was like that I mean that
was in stupid videos later of mine as
well believe me my first ones are
probably worse I guarantee you because I
didn't even write a script so it's
probably a lot of rambling at first I
can only imagine I know I tried doing
the non script thing very early on too
and I just like it came to the
realization that I just cannot keep a
coherent thought without a proper script
right so that's when I was like alright
well that doesn't work for me it's like
I need some sort of like organization
it's all part of your journey I think
it's harder you know finding your place
what makes you comfortable obviously I
don't do videos I do podcasts a lot and
for me it's like a combination of both
like some things I like to forward in
the script and a lot of things I like to
kind of like freestyle with but it's
that comfort zone you know saying and
you made a good point
I mean look I've followed politics kind
of testing for years you don't say and
even with the original crew or they went
you guys the sort so forth so I could
only imagine you know it's like hey
you're just getting there you know the
old regime left you're the new regime
and that's a lot of pressure like this
you can't understate that and you know I
got respect for all those guys that are
now you know over the DCP like I can't
even imagine you know saying being over
there and I'm like alright I'm next in
line like you know it's it's tough you
don't see anybody
okay I remember the the first dream that
I did on the under the planet destiny
channel um Jesus the chat was like who
are you you're like taking over it is
normal you know like it's normal but
that's just kind of like builds on on to
like that pressures like only [ __ ] it
hits with that almost like impostor
syndrome
yeah where you're like dude like [ __ ] do
like I belong here like you know so I
mean over time and stuff it's definitely
things that it takes thick skin yes oh
this little big very very thick very
thick so not that's a lot not let stuff
like that not let screen moves just let
me know to like not let that stuff get
to you and I mean over time like I work
Rito you know you develop develop it
there so it was it was a little bit
easier coming in but it was it still
hits you like it's in you know in
certain times absolutely it's funny now
though because once I stopped doing not
funny but like me it's wild when I
stopped doing the planet destiny podcast
just because there's not just not enough
time I have to work every other Saturday
so I just kind of need me time on the
weekends yeah um I would pop it into the
podcast every now and then and like I
there was a couple people that were we
had this sorry we had this meet or there
was this meme in the put in the planet
that's a neat chat where it was like
worst ft after he left no mmm
so now after like a couple of years of
me doing that and I saw that trend but
like with me and there were some people
like don't get me wrong it came from an
interesting in kind of nice place
mm-hmm but some someone in in the chat
had said something along the lines I was
like wow am really carried this podcast
and I was just like mmm
I mean I appreciate but that's kind of
dickish so you could relate yeah
absolutely so you see that yeah
it's crazy when you get that different
perspective of like now new people are
seeing new different faces and you know
they were kind of used to seeing
familiar faces so now you think weird
man gonna say to the trip yes
speaking of planet destiny we're gonna
have moon here in a couple weeks as well
coming on so nice yeah so looking
forward to that one but man sounds like
you have been through quite the paces of
just about everything in this community
but final pieces
what made you want to turn into kind of
one of the one of the really kind of
stellar destiny photographers I am a
sucker like even like
IRL in real life like I love taking
pictures I'd like I am a sucker for
taking like um like flora and fauna
pictures like just flowers and stuff
like that I love doing that and my
Instagram like kind of reflects that
here and there but it's the artists at
Bungie are like gods here mmm
you know yeah but you know they're
they're creating change um and I feel
like a lot of people would that play the
game often seem to miss a lot of those
details yeah
so I love to be able to like go into the
game and just capture those particular
details that people may not see or they
just miss and stuff like that and a lot
of people have been receptive to it
that's why I have a public folder on my
on my Twitter where there's a collection
of just a lot of different screenshots
and stuff like that that you can just go
in there and down and download like if
you you know for your stream or your
podcast whatever you can just go in
there get what you want I tend to update
it like every new season with new stuff
I haven't yet for season of arrivals but
uh it's it's pretty it's pretty great to
be able to like appreciate stuff like
that I remember one of the first
pictures that I had uploaded to Twitter
that like got a lot of traction it was
something so small but it's just it's
the things that you miss it was the
reload animation of malfeasance
hmm so when you open up the malfeasance
and the cartridge comes out right that's
fully rendered and it's fully detailed
and the actual bullets of malfeasance
look like these tiny little needle darts
yes that fit into the gun and that I
know they have like this take and glow
to them
and that [ __ ] is cool and you don't get
to see that he was playing along not
paying attention to the to the animation
you're like oh damn and it's it's just
the thing it's like it's so quick like
it's it's so easy to miss because you're
into like the heat of the game yeah so
you know it's just small things like
that and then just taking like you know
scenic pictures or picture the
guardians which I'm getting people
asking me you know to take pictures of
them for the for the bunion fashion yeah
I've had a couple of people ask me you
know like hey can you take a picture of
my guardian I like the way you do it so
um yeah it's it's cool it's cool that
you know you can help and in in in one
of those like that puts that same thread
with the malfeasance I remember there
was a Bungie dev that commented on him
he was like I'm gonna pass this thread
along to the person who actually created
that because they feel like people don't
see that and appreciate that and I was
like holy [ __ ] that's why it's their
only yeah it was really cool it was but
I'm with you bro like they they really
don't get enough credit
it's besides the immaculate gunplay
besides you know I'm saying the the the
the attention to detail from the
artistry right you know the weapon
creation the subtleties like you said
with it with about faeces and a thorn
then you know mean me and he always
talked about you know we got like a nine
hundred or somebody does the skyboxes
these tremendous beautiful just oh my
god amazing Vista's right yeah you just
like look at this like you do prophecy
dungeon and you like look at this like
generations going through the on the
sparrow section and you seen all the
stuff intertwine I'm like this is nutty
like you're like they don't get enough
credit bro and the last thing and I
always champion is the sound team the
soundtrack nning don't get enough credit
like they orchestra muscles got
Sylvestre those guys even you know I
know I know Marty gets a lot of credit
from part one and rightfully so
O'Donnell but it's like even now like oh
so that's those guys are in their bag
man I'm shocked just how he just
recently did um remember he did the raid
music themes yeah he's breaking it down
no I was yeah I was like man I forgot
you're Oryx beat like that boss right
ominous I I go crazy every time I hear
last wishing and the sure Oh chief fight
as well as well as the escape for a mom
Riven I love that beat is nothing yeah
man they don't get enough credit from
from a purely production standpoint and
artistry standpoint the game really is
stunning on a lot of levels it really is
but yeah that's good it's good that day
forward that was cool afforded the the
stuff all right yeah and it's just I
don't know it again just as long as you
can people like appreciate small small
things like that I think that's that's
what makes it worth it bats
EXO stock Queens whoa but you know about
that be what that joint is hard
yeah there's some epic ones to like for
sound the gambit theme uses great clips
yes yes yes we may be getting this I'll
be curious which version we get backups
epic stew because like the rock remix is
always fun but it can unset victoy and
resumes yes yes I get mad every Oh every
time I low-key every time the game of
what's come up i lo T Loki harass Geoff
Keighley so I'm like so when it's
definitely the game gonna get selected
faster now man
I just want a nomination you don't say
at this point I don't even care like
they should be in the mix you know
that's me I get all my harassment ray
I love it I love it I love it
well speaking of you know everything
going on at least recently uh first time
for this season for iron banner mmm
wanted to see what your guys thoughts on
it were how you guys are liking the new
guns we can start with those actually
the new auto rifle the new sidearm if
you guys are liking the new perks and
the new guns where you stand in him then
we yeah I am bana
um well haven't really used them I
literally just got a fool's remedy yeah
I tried using the sidearm and it's a
full lot of Sorrows so I play with
controller and I felt like the moment I
started shooting just like my aim what
yeah what else
yeah when all of yeah sorry I have to
get used to it I like certain sidearms
unfortunately fool's remedy doesn't fall
into the archetype that I enjoy me you
had to do similar continues funny you
said
of for Emily but yeah it doesn't fall
I'm alone some mm-hmm I'm a lover I'm a
last hope
okay yo Millar I'm actually digging a
new one so oh really
oh what you call you know what I shout
the Tassie reach light baby I like me
brief like a kinetic I really do but up
good to you could you say I would think
I get it reached like what's the season
before done that was the Dorian side of
dawn right yeah okay God love that one
for some reason I don't know it just
feels good but I'm I'm with you on fools
remedy for controller users it just felt
like it was all I just didn't feel
accurate you know I'm just like it's
your Katya classic comic like oh this is
better but it is anything matter for me
like it don't feel good to me like it
may be so that's honestly I wonder the
difference because I've been messing
keyboard since it was it ever an option
I was on PC for massive keyboard so how
are you like fools remedy for me I
actually easily like it like because I
can you know and potentially and like I
had to get sidearm kills and I got one
and then I was like oh here we go like
this it's actually not a bad option
it hits pretty reasonably yeah and then
now the new auto rifle that one that one
I'm digging well I got a 40 panel yep I
got a pretty decent roll on that one
actually and I was pleased what do you
guys think of that one well job before
path I've been a fan when it first was
introduced I mean I've always liked it
you know now to me six hundreds are just
in a sweet place so I've always wanted a
kinetic 600 that I can use because the
other kinetics were like either being
phased out I think was like duty-bound
and then the other one that was really
good was ghost Primus from the Leviathan
ray which I have that's a classic cold
Medina feels good it's just that it just
sucks I can't put you know anti burial
mod on it I can't you know say like you
go got the new flavor with it so just
like these old guns with the old times
10 masterwork that don't do nothing just
like yeah you know boy no foot forward
path is definitely I don't have the
right back to standard stock kind of
roll I think the one that salad didn't
kind of gave me a fright
like those aren't a stock they're all
random all those are right now so
orangey so yeah I think it's decent the
roll I got I just want one with a PV
econo roll Oh like I feeding frenzy and
multi kill clip like I got give me a PvE
roll but I got the PvP roll that I
wanted that's a yeah so I like it
um you know I'm probably not gonna get
me to move off of my somewhere right now
shout out the Aries who's in probably in
a chat yeah I'll be get that but um so
but for anybody who's looking for
academic 600 that's the way to go you
got to get your hand on it maybe you
could free up some exotic slots from
other things if you don't want to use
cirrhosis and all those stuff what about
you name um I you know I just got a like
one that I thought was decent enough to
start using neat thing is it's very it's
very difficult to pry off my blasphemer
from my kinetic dude I sort of clean
yeah it's it's so hard but you know I
play with other things just kind of like
keep it fresh from time to time but he
ain't just it I see my numbers go down
every time I start playing with
something you just cuz I'm not used to
it yeah so like you know I play like a
couple of matches and like I'm like
doing I'm like it feels like I'm
throwing just like mm-hmm the the
forward path that I got no though what
do you run a blasphemer if that's who
you so it's a curated mm-hmm it's the UM
it's got accurized high-caliber quick
draw and opening shots to work yeah I
can see why it's hard to press that's
yeah well funnily enough so you remember
the the first like two missions in
shadow keeper they kind of force you to
do altars of sorrow to like tear free
and then you get a chest okay that was
the first drop on shadow keep launch Wow
are in Jesus yeah so I like I saw and I
kept it and I was like me
to keep it you know just in case of
always like slick shotguns cuz they do
kognito I don't know if you were I can't
you know if you were super into like
black ops or one or two but yeah
remember the KSG oh absolutely you know
I loved the KSG because it was a slick
shotgun it had a none bigger arranged so
naturally like these like those slick
shot ease for me are like super fun
because they're high-risk high-reward
yes you know I've posted several videos
of why I play with them because you will
understand always get someone that's
just like mindlessly holding w yup
coming at you and if you if you know
you're kill cat your kill distance with
them like you're just like waiting for
him say okay you're done it's funny you
said that because how you feel about
slugs and I've always liked slugs
first way you've been rewarded for being
loyal now because floods got the buff
yeah as well 30% IV your home yeah how
you feel about that is how I feel a with
Lord of wolves
everyone apes be so like me I can keep
distance to say it's amazing so it's the
same thing like I'm antimatter in that
regard because it fits my place now but
I could totally see where you're at with
that way that's done no it's it's been
super fun and mm-hmm I'm sad what I'm
sad because this is this is a gun that's
gonna get sunsetted which one which one
we miss a little because poor are our RP
shadows which Omer is going blasphemer
all that's gonna get some sixty yeah
there's a piece that a homie recipe yeah
I'm like I'm trying to I'm trying to get
it close to 5,000 kills as crucible
kills you know I'm at 4800 right now oh
you'll get some I'm close to just kind
of hit that milestone before I can't I
can't upgrade it any any more thousand
and just like set it in the vault and
just leave a nice even number and don't
go over because you know like just just
leave it retired I know I'm like in a
state of glory I know seriously mmmm but
he's like you got
now start recruiting now you gotta see
you to think this is the problem you
gonna have you have that emotional
attachment like how I have to certain
ones that we see that 1060 be like oh no
it's gonna go you got to start
recruiting now who's next that's good
take the spot like I don't touch recluse
no more and mountain top because I know
me I'm like those are my wind buttons so
who's the new next in line what are you
thinking about who's your next who the
next kids just gonna take the mantle
honestly I don't know I don't have one
yet got nothing that's one that's one of
like my bigger downfalls when it comes
to comes to this stuff because like
shepper oh I can't run [ __ ] I know a
chaperone because I run graviton oh that
was gonna ask what was your energy slot
and that answers that um though graviton
that's got like 13 K kills on it is
there you go my hand since like I
started using it again how does how does
chaperon feel compared to blasphemer if
you do toy around you still as
successful you know I feel like I'm a
little bit more successful with my
blasphemer than I am with with chaperone
I don't know what it is but I can I can
safely say that there's been times with
chaperone that I feel like I know I
would have gotten a kill and I don't I'm
not sure if it's if that has anything to
do with like base stats or anything like
that or just like the physical aspects
of the gun cuz isn't fallout figured it
out you know different like barrel
bodies for yeah barrel links and stuff
like that I don't know I feel like I've
always had a lot more success with mmm
with blasphemer than and Shappy I was
gonna say I'm trying to think what else
is even hanging around long enough for
what good bone structure might be one
that's like I think gonna live for a
little bit there's not a lot of options
though so I mean blasphemy I think yeah
I think I'm this
we'll retire once beyond light hips
that's that's the life expectancy that
it has it and then I'm like then I'm
gonna have to find something else to
kind of like replace it yeah start now
cuz I'm telling you right now you're
gonna fall in that comfort zone it's
hard to get out of it because you know
what works already I already feel that
way like so here's a here's a thing
so when I play with my Titan mmm and
this is gonna sound totally nerdy as
[ __ ] when I play with my Titan I
typically don't bring over graviton and
blasphemer mmm
interested that stays on my warlock yeah
that stays on my warlock I thought I was
are cool
this is how my Titan at least the way
that I've currently currently been
playing it because season of dawn and
season upworthy I pretty much
exclusively played my warlock I kind of
left my hunter and my Titan in the dust
but I started playing it again and I've
been running Monte Carlo with him that's
a good that feels good yeah it is it's
really good and so like I have this
little build with my tiny label yeah
let's go go for it know what exotic all
you want to know which would you do
severence enclosure really sure exploder
that is on PvE yes okay mitem pvp it
works with shoulder charge hmm and if
you are close enough to people mm-hmm
when you get your initial kill you will
kill anybody that is within like five
five meters with Severns enclosure so
there's been there's been moments where
like if there's like three people
capping a point and I'm just paying my
little heart out towards like B or
something and I managed to get that one
all about I'm gonna go down because
they're standing right next to each
other capping the point anyway fun so
that's one Montecarlo so I can get that
melee up you know all the more
consistently yeah exactly it's really
it's an underrated exotic dude it's
super underrated but
yeah no that's um that's so great that's
over I got a China yeah check it out it
is cool bill you could try it out what
are you I'll think about it I've just
stared at that exotic and I'm just kind
of going I don't I that just didn't
didn't seem like it was going to do that
much but yeah in the right situation I
guess I could see exactly I was gonna
say it's incredibly situational it's not
something that you're gonna take
advantage every single time you get a
shoulder charge kill with what but when
when it happens it's satisfying as hell
again like that multiple like killed it
rocking its told her to - I got I will
say it's all much harder to get these
weapons to drop these IB weapons to drop
yeah so kinda wanted to bring that up so
you've got two new rizky refresh weapons
coming back but you got the full
loophole to go between yeah it comes for
I've seen people asking for the idea of
either a deliberate way to go after some
of these guns or anything of that nature
I wondered if you guys think Iron Man
was just like still the token slot
machine but you've got I mean
everybody's like hey I got my set of
armor I've got plenty of the old weapons
but I want the two new ones there's no
way to directly go after those
especially after we've been working with
the prismatic recast her for so much
this season it's the exact opposite know
most feels that much worse because you
can go I can go after cold denial and
guillotine over and over and over and
over and over over here I've got 15
things to pick from and I'm just like
I've got a lot of tokens and I'm like
I'm gonna burn through all these and get
like one role and question out of the 15
things are the older iron banner stuff
1,300 or those are 1060 stuff those are
now newer so then they drop these like
say a swarm of the Raven for examples a
prime example everybody went for that
thing when it was you know in the meta
it's not quite as cool as it was still
pretty good grenade launcher but now if
it drops now yeah it's 1360 so whatever
the lining for the for the new version
again yeah and since we got him here he
seemed like he had an opinion about it I
wanted to open open the box of
sunsetting
and we've we've mentioned this we talked
about it last week when you weren't here
and this is like a prime example if now
we're seeing a whole reissue thing which
is like I was for sunsetting he was
against we ended up coming to kind of a
middle ground in general on it and then
we're like probably for both of us don't
like Tassie set like reissues was an
issue that I saw for lots of different
people talking about be like I don't
want to go after the same thing and now
we're seeing that prime example for
specifically iron banner now like Ford
path and two weapons get it like new
perks which one's good one wrote very
odd Plett for the reissues just what's
your thoughts about son settings since
here the guess they got we gotta we
gotta ask him that kind of now this
coming up - I'm okay with it for weapons
I'm against it for armor okay it in
trusses two furnaces below to break that
down cuz
anybody who's played any power level
power level enabled PvP activity can
because you see a lot of the same things
you see a lot of more recently now for
example you what you're most likely
seeing a lot of summoner a lot of nine
hunger or mountaintop well particularly
just freaking Manta yeah kid I'm sorry I
know I don't sure you like the game but
it oh I'm wishing I kid that was what
I'm like yeah what's the date all your
exploration so in in that case scenario
like just seeing that stuff over and
over and over again and it gets very
tiring I mean it's it's honestly one of
the reasons why I kind of don't really
care for and and it's one of them I
don't care for trials of Osiris mm-hm
because you're basically just going up
against the same thing every single time
and it gets it gets very tedious it gets
very frustrating then and I'm not a
threes player like I love the chaos of
66 keeps me on my toes
but and in PvE it's it's basically the
same thing
alright Riven get out your grenade
launchers get out your I don't know
what's happening now I'm sorting them
now Drinker now that's not that that's
actually gonna get chasers on Tuesday
yeah it's gonna be a little less so you
know or like more recently with like the
sanctified mine or garden of salvation
it's a zeniff age whisper of the worm
and you know it's just it's the same
thing every single time yeah and I can't
imagine that Bungie wants to create more
weapons right that are cool but people
are still kind of holding on to some of
those like mountaintop or wendi-go
hammer head and stuff like that so in
that sense I'm for it but when it comes
to armor that's a little bit harder to
kind of like get particularly with
a solid stat role um preach a few
eminent and master working it is not
cheap Oh resources brother resource
exactly sources about that before yeah
so it's not cheap to master work a piece
of armor like you got and you got to be
like all right I got a commit to putting
this ascendant oh yeah shard on here
especially if you don't really run night
falls which I don't
so whatever shards I get I'm like [ __ ] I
got to make sure you know I'm gonna
commit oh no it doesn't matter because
it's not going forward so that's why I'm
against armor just because resources are
really hard to come by especially if you
don't do night falls yeah stat rolls is
not easy to come around one get those
Nazis yeah which is probably why they're
introducing transmog in year yeah but
they look exactly for the look cuz you
know if like for example for me my
warlock has the thorium holt chest nice
and that has a really high intellect
role and i dun't her eight for us that's
exactly that's what i want but it come
beyond light dot set those shards that
the prism the prisms it's not gonna
matter anymore I basically have lost
that yeah so now I'm gonna have to look
for something new that's why I'm against
I'm against the Sun setting of armor but
when it comes to weapons like you make a
good point when armor in terms of the
stat roll you know me because we all
know how hard it is to get those good
roles you know thankfully they've
increased this I felt dispassionate
they've been more forgiving with a lot
of the drugs I did privacy I got a lot
of high sixty roles I'm starting to see
them a little bit more in the wild but I
do feel you because you've got all these
different layers of orangey already
right then you resources are limited
right so when you do get these assesses
charge you do get a golf ball and all
this stuff you know you've got to think
about really committing and then for
them to say okay now we're taking this
away it is it is it's a hard yeah it's a
hard pill as well I do
understand your point on that weapons
again Mimi and II have met in the middle
um there is a part of me that is
enjoying having to think about what I'm
going to use come be online I'm not
gonna lie from a weapon standpoint there
is a part of me that does enjoy saying
okay you know what
reclusa had you run you know which glad
you run I got to start picking
replacements so I I've actually come
alongside to east side on that will
never mean we'll never meet on the
middle and exotics he knows that we will
fight tooth and nail blood and teeth it
will go down oh I want to hear this oh
yeah you don't want to hear cuz it'll be
another two-hour show as we make it
really simple when it came to Sun
setting I was gonna say everything and
he cannot stand to see exotics kill see
you see your face you see your he wants
your Gravatar late school he wanted gold
he wants to kill your leg bro it's
barely become effective in PvE with the
unstoppable pulse month that you can put
on armor instead of a gun I know you
know like he's like no I was like the
idea was for a while though a lot of
people do crutch on certain things as
you're saying it's like you live on your
recluses your mountaintops enough but
there are certain exotics that get that
same effect so it's like well now if you
take out the recluses the mountaintops
and those types of things going into the
new raid
everybody's gonna probably narrow it
down to very short list of exotics and
they're probably all gonna be trying to
work with those when it comes to
whatever kicks off in the fall so you
still have this thing and and my
question to him was like okay yeah so it
was year six it was a year seven when I
used to joke but at least we know six
actually exist now that's new I was like
a here six raid should you still be able
to take whisper into the year six raid
because it's a year one exotic
that's a good question honestly yes
why because whisper is not the same
powerhouse as it was back in when it
first came out great if we're living and
that's particularly yeah again but on
the other side if they did have the Sun
setting in place and it got to live in
its shining moments when it was powerful
then it had a chance to live but then it
would also be sunset so mm-hmm yeah it's
like now whoever is not as big of a deal
but say okay what about anarchy
everybody and their brother other
brothers mother uses anarchy right now
for next to everything if like keep
taking that thing for it like if there's
something that's that good exotics right
now there's like 150 of them we have a
lot so it was just the idea if they want
to continue to introduce exotics that
can shine I always wonder how much like
how many heavy machineguns can you make
like xenophanes it's cool it's
definitely a unique thing but we've got
we had delirium which is better than
most we haven't had that many exotics so
even the legendaries had their pieces
you've got what thunderlord and
xenophanes now for exotic machine guns
heir-apparent yeah
in heir-apparent there you go so but the
thing is so like we already have where
we have like a slew of legendary weapons
that are moving out of the game come
beyond light yeah we don't know how much
more exotics are gonna come with beyond
light so if they were to do an exotic
sunset they would be basically a sun
setting almost every exotic that came
out in the game up until seasonal
arrival which are the handful of them
and from what I know Bungie doesn't
really like to take away tools too much
from the sandbox mmm-hmm so that's
probably one of the reasons why they've
made the decision to keep at least you
know exotics from Sun setting no and
again it's not like it's not like at
least when we're looking at you know
like champions and stuff like that which
just seems like that's the direction
that they're taking a lot of life into
it's not like a lot of those are super
super handy it's like I think maybe
Ariana's Val and the divinity both have
like intrinsic perks but I mean Alice I
love iolite breath
oh yeah it's like those are the few that
have like intrinsic perks that are kind
of useful in those activities but you if
you take a look at like a lot of those
other exotics just now pulse rifles are
becoming viable in like a grandmaster
knife all for example because you're
able to use that armor mod that grants
every exotic unstoppable yeah right and
that was before that was a thing too
which is nice to see that because that
was the other piece I vest tours like
exotics I would love to see those have a
slot for each barrier unstoppable and
overload just yet a lot to use those
mods so hey it's pulse travels this
season or its auto rifles whatever you
can use that exotic and if I can take a
soros with the Auto rifle mods that
we've got I've been keeping me alive
that's where it's gonna give him new
life and that I'll give you it was
before some of this started to come out
when that made hats oh yeah that's fair
and I think there's excited again to
meet a middle cuz we don't go fight yes
but I think that's what we could do to
meet in the middle is to excite you
specifically right because I understand
your position on it my thing is you know
maybe like I said you can that you said
those mines right so when the seasonal
artifact comes out it's like hey pulses
sidearms or whatever that the meta is
going to be for barrier and overload
right that dole can now be applied to
exotics well you baby you put that on
the armor slot right that allows it to
you now how exciting is it gonna be the
use Rat King up in there and that has
overloaded my yours a like everybody's
on the Rat King like there could be fun
moments where older exotics that haven't
got touch can get can get a chance to
shine and the last the last part I would
say is that they've proven I know you
mention the whisper thing they've proven
that there's certain exotics like I said
they either bring down or they bring up
right I always thought based on the meta
and I think that thing is just a
shifting thing where other things can
get life and improving with graviton
Lance and sunset Sun shot that remember
those initially were kind of weak at D
to launch the buff cosmology got buffed
for a mom
over time and we were like holy we
looked that SunShot and those explode
it's a party going off when you playing
essentia I was literally talking to a
dude on Twitter today and he was like I
think we talked about knowing hunger he
was like yeah I can't you know take that
out of my energy slide or something I
wouldn't use for it yeah yeah he's like
there's no he was like there's no his
point was there's no exotic energy um
energy exact that he's excited about I'm
like bro have you i named like four
right i was like a graviton sunshine
Ariana's and i'm like you haven't used
those they say hello they what they say
hi to you right now so he's like
sunshine I haven't touched that to the
beginning the d2 I said bro you need to
touch it again it's it's that good he
was so he's now playing and he's like yo
you're right like this is crazy to think
yeah so it again is ways they can do
stuff to like I say buff older exotics
or archetypes that in general like we
all agree snipers kind of need a little
love right now as far as PvE Scouts like
yeah Scouts especially yeah Scouts
especially they could do things at the
sandbox so we'll see we'll see I think
we could meet in the middle there though
you know it's a sad fact what's up
um oxygen never got a chance to shine
got a chance to shine before it's
getting sunsetted I'm so mad I had so
high hopes for that gun now I had dragon
flashback I was I was going all and I'm
like this is still like sad side of
pinnacles yeah yeah yeah and then
mountaintop recluse or they're scary
it's just funny to see that all of the
crucible pin or at least like most of
the crucible pinnacles mm-hmm excelled
both in crucible yes all right you got a
loaded question that's all right no
question was with me like throw throw
crowns of sorrow dude yo like I had
control you know actually I will say to
that no literally loaded question toyed
around because now you've got the I
cannot remember the name of the perk but
you put it on a bonus of are bursts no
no for you for oxygen
the
one second no it's the new perk they
took it out sympathetic arsenal put that
on a bow with loaded question every time
you reload you're sitting mag capped so
you have it just waiting why don't you
think about hang with the explosion
that's fire I didn't think about that
it's beautiful what you can do with that
combination Wow you shoot a but you
reload constantly so shoot a couple
switch off always waiting always waiting
that's that's the essence of loaded
question you want that full clip
explosive I'm gonna say that I can't
it's beylin so like you only enjoy that
this season but it was like that was one
of those with sympathetic arson although
I'm like cool and that's something that
can truly take advantage of it so that's
super cool dude but that's what makes
you wonder about the fall and we'll get
back to my other topic here in a second
is yes sir
how big of an influx cuz we're losing a
lot obviously blasphemer loaded
questions lots of pinnacles mmm it's
getting to be whittled down I mean
people were saying there's like gonna be
one or two swords I mean the lists were
getting pretty small how big wanted to
ask both of you how big of an influx how
big is this new loot pool that they
introduced with beyond light how big do
you think it's gonna be oh man dude it's
gotta it's got to be substantial because
we're gonna see a lot of stuff leaving
and I don't know it's a Loutre shooter
do you get you got to have you got to
have heavy chase you gotta have stuff to
chase and I don't know I mean I feel
like though I feel like they're gonna do
good you know a lot of if we're looking
in comparison you know a lot of people
type tend to kind of look at the
seasonal stuff more than it should
you know like they'll look it's like oh
you know they told me this season only
has like three weapons with it two
exotics or whatever but then it's like
you got to think about the fact that
this is this is not meant to be like a
DLC bridge this is just kind of meant to
satiate you meanwhile we get a bigger
the content in the year because I mean
if you take it if you if we step back a
little bit and we look at destiny one we
didn't have anything between house of
wolves and taken king that was six
months travel to the same sandbox if
nothing but just trials was basically
the only thing that kind of kept that
good because people still wanted to go
to the light house that didn't go but
now we have at least something to kind
of play and chew and mole around with
and so you know the the big fall
expansion comes around so I think
they're gonna do good I think we will
see a good half of like possibly like a
forsaken sized type of like luke cool
coming in yeah yeah but you um I think
it's it has to be you know I mean
obviously if you're gonna introduce
sunset and you're gonna make a big
commitment to a blog post about why this
needs to happen you clearly have to have
a plan in place to you know to basically
satiate that so yeah I think it's coming
I got complete confidence know it's one
thing about bungee when it comes to
September not only do they introduce
things they always rework the backbone
of the game they always introduce either
subclasses perks just new things I mean
even last year I I remember we would
like finishers like what's this like you
don't like yo I didn't even know I
wanted this thing you never knew you
wanted like this there's so many think
about there's so much like revenue
potential I would buy foolish things
like Karate Kid doing stuff I would you
know sweep the leg I would just spend
money doing this that like they've
opened up a whole new revenue stream for
things I didn't think I needed so I have
full confidence you know they're gonna
kill it you know we're gonna get that
raid I will say this that I'm proud of
them though is I was under the
impression that with the expansions name
right like you know we got shadow key we
got the dungeon yet we had a new dungeon
and we had a raid right so I'm like wow
that's a lot of content so greedily I'm
like we can't ask any more dungeons so
you don't saying because so to see prop
see up in this I was like okay this is
cool yeah yeah
so again gotta get him credit like like
you said this is a this is a ever
changing game it's a game as a service
in a sense you know these smaller things
are to keep us afloat to keep in yeah
meant to be and I'm at peace with it
finally I was even knows I was very
upset during the transition at first
because you like what you like and you
got used to it you know but as a studio
and then if you look at the resources
right we like robots vicarious they look
I can't as selfish as I am I can't ask
them to do that without all of these
resources you know yeah so now it's just
like okay cool this is what we're gonna
get but my whole thing with them I just
look at this my only beef with them and
I always stay hard on them on this part
is with the annual content like you see
how we're doing stuff with these stories
with with you know what um Eris and
drifter and you know you got the devil's
ruin quest and it like I want those
narrative threads told right and
cinematically tied into each season
correctly so it's cohesive you know
that's a must for me I'm never gonna get
my boot off their neck quartet like
please connect these things in a full a
cool way
what don't absolutely I'm good I'm good
and then I recognize you know what
September's the big boy you know this is
me and I'm good I'll leave you alone for
the most part but to your question
ultimately big big sandbox has come in
big
I think additions to the loophole new
exotics they gotta kill it we got
darkness subclasses in a way you know
coming in a way okay that one that one's
a big one because not only is it thus
like an entire new subclass to kind of
play around with but it's a subclass
that's customizable on unlocked like the
ones that we currently have are the only
really father the old subclass is gonna
get a rework to get that same
customizable feel
so according to Luke Smith they're using
this this new dark like darkness stasis
as an experiment to see how it works and
if it's successful most likely they'll
work on opening up like those other
older subclass trees up mm-hmm so you're
gonna have literally more player choice
just on the new one as a me right be
curious how that's how fast people are
like all dude do this all I can't
imagine it's not gonna take like a week
and be like yeah do this to all of them
right now just a jump whatever but like
I miss like hey do you want this perk of
this perk in so you're not everybody's
there maybe some optimal but hey I want
to go for a certain build style and
he'll let me mix it up so yeah I agree
now my only wonder for the fall it's
like weapons I'm with you guys like I
think it's got to be big it's got to be
a chunk because I remember there was a
graphic somebody put together of like
what was gonna remain in each archetype
for each weapon and it was pretty stingy
in a lot of places so I mean I don't
know if you asked for 40 or 50 or
whatever but I mean I don't know that
number to ask for but it's got to be a
big influx but my question is mm-hmm and
this is where I wonder when you talk
about armor do you think they're gonna
do anything else to armor in the fall
like like a 3.0
I don't think so mmm he's hospira kid
right now
and I mean it's a long shot hope believe
me I know but I mean when you like that
point it's hard to see I mean I don't
know because I'm just a caveman that
plays the game and I don't have the big
brain they do too because I come up with
this stuff um it's hard to see what else
they can open up with with our current
system with armor because we have you
know we we now have the ability to
change the the elemental elemental stuff
on it we have to the to mod slides we
have a lot of possibilities for builds
and stuff like that I don't know
outside of transmog what else they can
add to the armor system mmm aside from
maybe like what they did with gambit
Prime and armor set perks I would love
to see that I love that but let me ask
you guys a question no realistically as
much as we all want on a set perks does
that play nice with armor sunsetting no
it does not and that's what I worry now
because we can't reduce unsetting you
really can't have some sets to hold on I
don't know I'm not that you can't but
it's just gonna be for limited times you
know that's what I mean something where
I could see sets be valuables arrayed
like if there's a deep stone crypt
Center on them I'm which it'll always
use a bone there you could even keep the
set in your vault packs but you don't
worry about it going forward cuz that's
it always usable in that vault it's
almost it's almost like we had that
already yeah I know worked already
mm-hmm
but for some reason for some reason not
a thing I don't know I will die on the
hill that wrath of the machine had the
best investment system in Gustin talk
your talk and for the rapid machine guys
you always give you a hard time but I
always say the loophole and the
investment system with that raid was by
far the best I will always give it up
unrest on my CV shadows any bad machine
yes lumen I always give it up because it
always made me want to run it number one
you had the key system receive a key
thing so that even if you did the raid
already you had investment to still do
it for a chance at a reward you had to
do rat had the greatest loop system and
I'm not to mention not to mention that
like the energy and the heavies the s
had an elemental burn yes like that's
what kept me running cuz I was like [ __ ]
I love the ex machina I want and you
know on all the burn row shot let's talk
some warlock talk for a second remember
to the mattress chest we had it helped
you when you were doing the bomb thing
what was it the only exactly because
they had Reaper consistent with the
mechanics of the raid and like why are
we not doing that no more
oh yeah red weapon and armor perks
please let that come in the fall like I
missed it like they had it lined up it
was no reason to go away from that I'm
with ya I'll die on arrow which you were
like that oh crap rat did it right was
what it is they did a percent like the
best that that's been the best
investment system when it comes to like
an endgame activity like yes honestly
nothing in d2 right now has America to
to that I'm if anything it's been kind
of lacking it yeah
throughout its throughout its history
mm-hmm I mean I ran rap a lot because a
lot like I don't know dude I I used to
read a lot in d1 in a lot of that kind
of like died down on on destiny too
because mm-hmm I don't know saying thank
the the visuals in the armor it just did
it didn't give off to like the the
fantasy aspect of that we had in destiny
one mm-hm we had reduced like weapon
archetypes in in the actual loophole you
know like last wish doesn't have a heavy
machine-gun he doesn't have a sidearm
the point and if we look at Leviathan
the life in original Leviathan route
spire and stuff they were missing
weapons
oh yes that were taken out of that loop
mm and insert it into the raid blares
mm-hmm ooh and then those sadly were
like you do an entire raid lair and
experience with six people and you got
two drops from it yes yeah that was the
number of drops doesn't really like
super upset me because it was just it
was a smaller thing right
she's calling that's the size of it
broken any we got a call at how he got a
call shout out to the extra extra reset
it DD no the raid homages don't give
that wow factor he made a good point
like like you I remember when you're
shot again I give crota guys a hard time
we're gonna say but crota said Shh bro
let's talk about it you know say like
the joint I mean my mom wore like
looking like a vampire would do with the
next you know you know what's edited you
you got that as far as your DCP pics I
already know you'd oh yeah bro like that
set again it's epic effect a fed
aesthetically with what you were doing
and I gotta be really what show as much
as I love prophecy as much as I thought
I was all the new armor there's a reason
why though alright okay say what you go
say cuz I'm upset with one thing Nona
like wow I got do this great raid and I
got this Louis Vuitton dye toe logo on
my chest like I don't worry too much
[Music]
because because very busy because that
was the ever first set okay yep that's
the one they don't get of a diverse and
they put in a speciality exactly they
want to give players a reason to play it
is kinetically not tied to yeah that's
what we know damn well precisely I've
done to do a die toe like what what
who's selling die toe I armor it's fine
clearly Valentine's has died out like
thing but I mean
so these that's why they do have the
original trial set as also a set that
drops from it which makes more sense
than the data one about it I can at
least appreciate the fact that so when
pit of heresy came out yes
I was excited for it I was like holy
[ __ ] this is and then I ran it with pyro
and we did the first encounter just
popped up in that purple Engram came out
and I made it up and it was a dream bein
our myselfi story that you're forced to
get already pinnacle activity check it
out master words for French oh and then
master work with trash stats on the end
of the garbage step no sixty let's go
hasn't even been fixed hot fire for you
for that hard work that was probably to
me it was just such a kick in the yeah
yeah I got you yeah it's so I can know I
can appreciate that they gave this this
you know dungeon not only one but two to
chase he's gotta do we got a do bad it
on them we can't let you off the hook
we could we come from the crotas rate we
come sooner or as you put it here and
are in the discord chat what my D one
character looked like and this is
something they know you'll have to pull
it out look there this is something that
you cannot replicate in d2 with any of
the raid armor it's a take me the right
the end of rise of iron every one of
those sets in the end when they redid
those raid armors with the spikes out of
protons with all four sets we're amazing
like I can't look right now cuz what it
is it's for y'all remember his deck for
all he's got the cook he's got the
necrochasm that he's got the the crowed
I believe the crow to set chess piece
what what is that the crow - helmet - no
actually the crota chess piece and the
rest of the armor is the ornamented set
from Kings
fall from case fall yes you can't look
like you look like oh my god you look
like a good dark God and it is this
beast is beat so you you see a character
like that and destiny one in the tower
and you're like whole like water in
every tomorrow that's that's the goal
exactly exactly not been something like
that in destiny - yeah sorry crystal I'd
know and did it the chest like can we
see he said to hold on yeah it's an
image but try to work on it so you do
see it but on again it's those moments
in d1 again that made me play them read
that me I never forget why people want
to know why I'm so fascinated with
trials I remember it was like yesterday
I went to the tower it was another
warlock and he was out here looking like
Anubis and I'm like what is go where do
you get this that like I'm doing this
now like that's what they miss and again
I step in the right direction out of the
everywhere store I'll give you that step
in the right direction
however it needs to be playing exactly
exactly city GA let's go here we go yeah
that remember all he was looking like a
dog god that's fire that was five got
incentive mechanism in destiny one was
my graviton Lance that's what you know
once ty no one's surprise yeah I was
gonna say that's the one if it ever
comes back you'll lose your mind and I
think I remember on Twitter you were
like hoping with all the hive stuff
coming you're like necro remember you
were hoping for that secretly on Twitter
fire dude every day I think you guys it
may be I don't know if it's I feel like
when Scarlet Witch comes out which quill
which green like that's I put you the
name I know here he come with Christian
um I think that's why they already do as
governor I already always butcher it so
like I do feel they they're gonna
introduce Kings for though as the
reprised one like I know vault is coming
for this one are you early on yeah but
for some I mean ever know we might get
it
and I get it Oh know what that you know
what they can imply right but again
we're gonna see a reprise the vex
mythoclast oh we got to got it you can't
have vault of glass and not have back
smithing forward like it's a concern
we're with fate bringer and it's gonna
be late listen that alone will sell
people on that stuff flight oh allah
under personal you all i got to do is do
the could you imagine the dead their
productive marketing team t teaser
trailer and then while they're going
through all the wrong okay and then he
like to the dance you know now favorite
let people are going to if so many
people have such an emotional attachment
to these web it's gonna go crazy all
they would have to do is just like kind
of tease vault of glass right mmm just
like the with the new lighting and
everything but that season 14 if I begin
say to the screen to black and just have
the sound effect of ex-mayor class show
and then people dissolution gone you
know what yeah I know people tons of my
friends who quit desti that would come
back just for that that weapon those
weapons and that raid is beloved it's a
lot of people's dastan [ __ ] first
experience and yeah make this sit not a
ton of stuff all these Oracle sounds -
yeah yeah somebody's did a lot to keep
what I lost it so yeah the unlights
exciting I'm hoping there's so much we
don't know and it's the fact that they
like I don't know when they're gonna
tell us the rest and I know we still
have two and a half months till it's
gonna be a thing but I mean we're
wondering it's like okay so how much are
we gonna get like win is we know
cosmodromes coming back like for new
light in season 12 and then later on
we'll get more and then fog will
probably even after that and everything
like that nature so I'm very curious win
they'll tell us like wit teaser trailers
oh by the way here is your bonus raid
AHA and that thing drops man oh that's
gonna be crazy
well they said
for or for that also class three is over
if it's always the doldrums of spring
with worthy and drifter and everything
else that you know that's the perfect
place for them to be like hey just in
case you feel like this season's quiet
yeah we brought you back fog so even if
it's season the drifter here's vog lake
mmm-hmm season of worthy you know for
teens my guess if I had to wager now
it's 14 because that'll be the quiet
before 15 will lead into which Queen
right that's like yeah and of oh is the
spring quiet nature yeah yeah cuz they
said it's not coming at the start right
what do you say oh they confirmed that
oh yeah okay yeah sometime in year four
oh so it's not beyond light it's some
design beyond lore it's a Bri it's gonna
be packed already so it's perfect to
reprise that when it makes sense from
what from a content delivery standpoint
like it's it's it's basically old assets
that is just gotta you know bring up how
they're gonna like invisibly wall off
the part of Venus that cuz it's a patrol
zone is where you start mmm-hmm like how
are they going to just like have just
the zone in the skybox and nothing else
out there that's a good question I'm
sure they like block it off is like some
of the environment do you think they'll
have that opening section though with
Venus or do you think they'll more start
you inside and take that part out
no I think they don't you mess with my
nostalgia that's more of like they start
pulling Venus and at that point so I was
just kind of curious I noticed this I
don't you have this thing where you know
you know they could butcher your joy and
take that out words on their mouth just
to spring a fly it up in chat so I was
probably right the way it's gonna be
upset them made them leave and
everything talked about seems like the
scales over that I get what you say
hello jokes aside I listen it is
something they have to tackle right what
I can't see them get rid of it it's just
just for the simple fact that was
literally the essence of the rate was
creating that spire yeah even though I
know I just like it'll be like invisible
walls you just can't go around and
they're just gonna they're gonna have to
develop enough that you ya figure out
where you stop and that's basically it
so just be curious how they do I just
saw but I didn't want to ask you guys
for iron banner and stuff like that to
kind of bring it back to current times
since you know I could speculate about
the future forever matchmaking mmm-hmm
here you see your guys thoughts as iron
banner this is the first time they took
out skill-based in its pure connection
based matchmaking like it don't like it
I've just seen different sides of it on
Twitter so I just kind of curious where
you guys are standing now
the Superman curl I can't not look at
that one hair by the way dude it's
literally it's the Superman girl in dude
do you fix the hair and pick the one and
pull it down is it intentional I got a
no flight intentional okay cuz those
legs no like wait takes a lot of product
to keep the ship because here's a
disaster if I'm if I don't have stuff on
it so it's just it's the end of the day
I've been having this since like 8
o'clock in the morning so it started to
come down a little bit but anyways iron
banner so here's the thing mmm with the
matchmaking thing I know what play a lot
of crucible right I play a lot of
Christmas
mmm I don't consider myself like a
crucible though like
sweaty person obviously you're pretty
damn good though
I mean that's subjective I himself short
over here just asked Chris tough when
they go one-on-one I have it felt a
whole lot of difference hmm and I again
that's probably just because I don't I
don't see the crucible super objectively
I just go in there and shoot [ __ ] and if
I get shot cool if I shoot other people
cool good so um it's hard for me to
really tell too much of a difference
mm-hmm honestly like the big the biggest
thing that I can I can I've noticed
since we we did this change is control
matches now seem to be and I know I'm
gonna get [ __ ] if like either stark or
crit or like we're still watching right
now yeah although they lost them no you
have told you he be he be right back on
top like he do
but a Prescott apart scan agrees says
yeah I jungle wise connecting all you
know for me it's it's one of those
things where it is my experience has
been it's been a pub stop or I've
stopped I don't know it I don't feel
it's like in-between and you know look
from a connection standpoint for almost
what I have no issue from the idea so
hope not
yeah ever had an issue you know in that
respect now I have been running with
teams you know I'm saying a lot so I
don't know what the solo experience is a
lot this season I haven't really played
solo banner like I normally I play a lot
of solo better but this one this one I
didn't so you know I've been hearing
stories you know piano people just like
this is brutal you know saying just
trying to get stuff done and getting
killed I know you play solo a lot so I
don't you know or they go dance only I'm
to get him back on point he's making
some points there you gonna have you
back
alright I sorry about that yeah so the
one thing that I've noticed now is
people going with a bigger focus to slay
right so matches usually end up like in
a loss a little bit more now because
people just trying to like just you know
play they play clash but I feel like
before we have this change people played
control a little bit more objectively
and I know I'm the type of player who
kind of skips over zones but I am the
one I'm the one jerk who will capture
the first zone and just pretend to rest
that I got people to kill yo okay it's a
team effort other people who captured
the zone and obvious I'll get the kills
you know the same oh my god I got the
gunplay you go stand still just oh I'm
gonna use my weapon skills and my Nova
wipes to kill people you blueberry
sitting in the corner just stay there
stay alive don't die
will you at least put your foot or the
circle for a triple cam so that salad at
least put it really close to it in the
iron banner I will make the effort okay
and banner and better in banner I'll
make the effort cuz it matters more
there yes I didn't really get our
control you like with it so for overall
your experience don't you just feel like
you know different yeah okay like I've
played with you the majority of this
iron banner played it with with friends
and it's it's been either we steamroll
or we get steamrolled oh I'll say that
he just came for you he said them is
like the people who run ahead of strikes
and died and I just stopped by their big
goal by way you right in my experience
it'll be more like I'm going and then
I'll just blinked slightly further than
I intended and yeah there's no recover
one as more like yeah you don't have a
whole lot of recovery to its oblique or
like you got even less like soup wrong
your eyes all over did yeah like I say
for me ever playing mostly team this
iron manner so I don't have a full
perspective on what it's like to be
running solo banner with connection base
for me it's just been explosive it's
been you know we stomping or we get
mercy quick so from a speed standpoint I
guess the batches are going quick you
know I know a lot of the higher skill
guys love it you know and they're just
like hey I get to have some fun and I
don't have to you know play against
super sweaty all the time and you know I
get that you know and then there's you
know I just I just want to make sure
that we have enough evidence that people
who are running solo
or having fun cuz that's my concern you
know saying I know he have talked about
possibly like how we have in comp maybe
a lone Wolf's Creek you write like a
solo I am an acute for those guys who
don't have a stack cuz I would assume
again that can't be the funny funnest
you know going up against complete you
know stack so load I know you I know you
about to talk about it so that's where
I'm at I mean I can't really comment cuz
I'm actually having fun and my
experience yes when the times we got
stomped you know saladin throw up the
flag it was like we gonna mercy this now
and you know that was a shout to teaser
Teddy because um yeah concern came
through on US team concerned oh they
came through for match but then it was
like we would on like eight streak of
just stomping people and I see a friend
well you're the good side of it you're
like oh this is great yeah like you're
chillin in having a good time think
about the other a team I just played it
yeah see I put the other team that's not
great at pvp and are trying to get some
pinnacle gear and I know some bounties I
agree or probably like and that's see
this is the difference between me and
most cuz again I consider myself above
average PD play I'm not just you know
God definitely not but you know my thing
is I think about the health of the the
community of the game right I want
people to keep playing so if someone's
getting if they're telling me you know
like hey you know we gonna stopped I
hate it like I'm a trials guy I don't
want those guys to go away you need
those guys for the pool you know I mean
so that's why I want to make sure that
we actually still cater to the most some
level you know so they still stay
invested in want to play the activity
but II Europe I know you're not serious
no I mean it's I've seen I've seen both
sides and I can say it's like you take
the em test you take the the high level
skills and they're like man I'm so tired
that every time I go into a PvP match
it's sweaty right and sometimes they
just want to have fun this goes active
yeah it's like then when this goes
active I see
some of them post up like an ad kill
game and I'm like Jesus they love it I
was like and they're having an absolute
blast but the people in the other side
getting point one point one point two
and getting just stepped on like that's
one person who now feels like hey I get
to feel like a God for you know more
often because I'm playing against people
who aren't even near my skill level and
I can just squish them like bugs but on
the other side you have an entire team
hating their life and that's kind of
thing I'm with you guys I had some
mercied I had some I got mercy totally
get that and this is where like the solo
queue maybe the solo coup would be
skilled and maybe the regular one could
be connection cuz if you go solo skill
basically the main reason I'm even
bringing any of this up I've had the
back and forth I stopped some people's a
cool yeah I got squished cool but it was
there was one time I got squished it
wasn't like anything else I played and
if something played multiple matches the
way it was 78 to eight mm-hmm we didn't
hit double digits and I had three of
those kills I had three of the kills on
the bad team and no everyone no one else
some people had zeros couple of people
had it was point there were some
attractions they kept the wolves the
whole mercy I was like what team did
they put me with what's going on it yeah
and that can't feel good and in the last
point to jump on your point I don't know
if it was me but I did field spawns were
a little weird
well the game the game that I was
talking about yeah it was I always can
never remember the damn Maps it's the
necess one where heavy can be down
underneath between the two little and
yes yeah it was that one oh they were
spawn farming us constantly got it got
the site and it was a six-deck yeah I
know it was the six that caused it yeah
so if you're a solo player and you hit a
six stack that is running of that well
you will set that game down for a little
because it's just like was rough the
spawn the spawn killing was
crazy verse six so I get to your point
II if I'm you know the new guy and these
are my experiences yeah you know I can
understand I can relate to that
yeah that's rock it sounds like and
that's as like and I don't want to say
like hey the people who don't want to be
sweaty all the time they don't a place
wedding on but on the other side it's
like so what the really high skilled
person is is like hey I want to go crush
some people for a little while max talk
that talk
no but it's like that's what they're
going for and it's like but sometimes
for them it's like hey everything's
tense and I'm like okay for me tense is
at my level or worse if it's but if it's
like words let's just say let's just say
let's just get controversial if you're
that good you should be playing what
people would save sizes you stop picking
or the key that's a huge controversy on
Twitter and I'm always watching
different sides and I'm always kind of
curious it's just interesting it's like
so you want to feel godly for a little
while that's what they want and it's
always just interesting to see make it
in make it a harder for people want to
step into iron potassium iron banana
yeah it's just it's one and as I'm
average like I'm okay at PvP I don't
sucked I have some games where I do well
I had one where I went like 31 and had a
four and a half Katie and I'm like that
was actually felt good and so I had
those and that's the one where like yeah
they probably were getting tired of me
killing them because I was going off but
on the other side when I get I'm okay
and if I have three kills and we have a
total of eight points something's wrong
and I can't hardly move and I get a team
shot like three people running his
grouper and every person that's fine
I'll see and it's like that was the
extreme and no it was only have one that
was that bad Oh
so it was like most of mine like you
guys won some lose some and I'm kind of
like you name I'm like I'm not taking it
all that seriously work on my bounty
shooting people have fun messing with my
own stuff hey is this not hunger it hey
how's this forward path is it good is
the range now that it's minus 40 if I
got this week I'm having that new perk
is so minus 40 range we printed in the
submachine gun ah dude but it's
like when you get stepped on that bad
that's the times if you put yourself
into casual shoes they're like screw
this mouth and especially if that's one
of the places casuals can go for
pinnacles yeah kind of hurts a little
more yeah no I get it I get it so that's
that's the thing yet last sentence right
there that was an interesting one
because we have a hard cap hmm which is
the 1050 right that's that's kind of
like supposed to be the the stop point
for quote-unquote casual player right
because the initial the initial thing
for pinnacle power level was for those
who wanted out something a little extra
mm-hmm the chase and I think that's
where I think that's that's where iron
banner comes in that's gonna be for for
like that you know that demographic of
people that without are chasing that so
maybe like shirt to someone who doesn't
rain often this might seem like an
avenue for maybe getting a little bit
more power absolutely but I think at the
end of the day like it's definitely more
targeted towards like that that group of
people that are like all right you know
they're they're more involved with the
game than someone who will just kind of
like play a couple of hours a week so
yeah that's my dance with that like I
said it's it's a balance that they just
got a their figure I feel I still feel
that kind of experimenting I was not
surprised you don't say when I heard
that they were gonna do connection base
for this you know let's give it a shot
and stuff like that you know budge is
all about the numbers they're all about
data you know means yeah for sure
yeah they're compiling right now and I
was curious I'm very curious to see if
the next iron banner will remain that
way or what they what conclusion they
come up with based on the results of
this one I'd love to see them try a solo
skill iron banner be curious it'd be
interesting for connection for whatever
you play teams go stomp know whatever
yeah if you go solo skill kind of live
in your zone
I'd be interesting I love solo skill
comp I got a lot done in solo skill comp
so you know it helps you know it there's
nothing worse than I was that you know
solo guy you don't know like when you
start a match and you just know
you're playing up against a stack and
you just like it's gonna be over soon
enough yeah you like this again II know
like again I'm about average if I'm on
my team and I'm dominating and I'm
carrying the team we got a problem like
like like I'm here dominating and
carrying and looking like a superstar
out here just to keep it competitive
like nah that's what you just know okay
you know you see that mm-hmm
you I was gonna ask you guys real quick
since we're in the topic of iron banner
um but we've had basically the same
formula for iron banner Oh
since dust anyone mm-hmm
it's definitely aesthetically speaking
it's definitely geared more towards
having a thematic approach to the iron
Lords room but do you guys think it's
about time for iron banner to become its
own thing in what sense because if
you're if you if you take a look at it
it's it's a glorified control game yes
that comes around like three times per
season or whatever mm - like it like I
mentioned like if you look at iron
banner in d1 it's literally just control
but with a different set of rewards yeah
and now you know they've definitely done
a little bit more work where it you you
know you have like the fire pits for the
control you have the the difference of
the different like rule said you know if
you cap all three long ball down yeah
you have Saladin as the VI set of yeah
instead of checks but I feel like
we've gotten to the point where I've
ironed banner feels stale and I'm tired
like just just game mode why isn't but
like overall I think for a game mode
that comes around three times on the
lifetime of a season mm-hmm I feel like
it needs to become its own thing to get
to for two people to get excited about
it again because they work after a while
I'm sure for like most people it's like
oh iron Manor right got some bounties
maybe yeah there's some bounties to do
mm-hmm and there's a lot of there's a
lot of lore oh that they could they can
use to creating mmm like extremely
unique like PvP game like introduce a
capture capture the hill but with the
iron axe from the archives
orange let me let me jump because uh you
say it's the stuff she's touching me
because obviously law kognito iron Lords
podcast it was founded off of okay that
whole thing you know say rasa fire
you know but um look iron Lords are near
and dear to me I love that whole story
I love the lore behind it here's the
problem the problem is I love what
you're thinking but I think Bungie has
probably seen think about this the few
times that iron banner in d1 tried to be
rift tried to be clash right people push
back people were like oh why are we
gonna do this bring back control bring
back a truck we hate this I hate I'm not
playing iron band as weak because it's
this you know I've seen it like I was a
rich guy well I actually never got upset
when iron banner try to do another
moment why I was like let's go
it's just different like what's the big
deal you know but I'm not playing it
they're gonna so we know control iron
banner is the favorite I love that
they've got the thematic stuff and if
you remember I think was it a my damn
I'm losing track of my remember I'm your
Nona which one effort he came back
whispers burn reservoir it was it wasn't
she to hold for a little bit but
something like he was sort of her for
the bounty you
go to her yeah right they were trying
things and I was just like I thought it
was cool like do different this again
like you said there's so much with this
lore right yes so much with the Ironwood
like they could really do other things
pneumatically in conjunction with the mo
because I really do now it is kind of
stale after a while it's like okay I
just a pinnacle chase you do you bad as
you go okay cool but like there's so
much more you can do and to be honest oh
absolutely
I think Saladin is disrespected as a
character he's just that now like yeah
yeah like let's be real like we just
came off of season other unworthy and
just learned
we just that's been his friends all oh
yeah trash I hate that were season in
this no disrespect but I'm sorry I just
got a call had it but the big is we just
came off of an informational bombshell
bell winter now winter right I am Lord
who was secretly the son of whatever
wouldn't we like to know how Saladin
feels about this yeah we don't even get
normal dialogue from Saladin we get
nothing like nothing like okay I just
found out one of my guys was do you know
a plant from a from a war mind no big
deal we're not gonna talk about I don't
have any vengeance I don't have anything
you know I was gonna come drop this hot
pot and give you some weapons and leave
I never thought I never wrote that in
through that that lens that's why I get
so mad with them because this game has
such of the best lore that is not
connected that there's no connective
threads and no one feels away and
nothing I think they just need new ran
Lord doesn't move a probably I actually
disagree bro I think Lord does move it
if it's done and connected well because
you'll have an emotional attachment to
set then look how crazy we getting over
in vampire it's never got us like
handshake or bro hug or anything for
it's the biggest fan boy oh sorry ain't
even get to meet to do it any cinema yet
like hey late
oh boy same thing no bro hug between
Osiris and Saint bro I just saved you
like Wiz this ad these are huge things
see enough I mean he dance lawyer you
100 percent will move it will move a
product look at season of dawn alone
yeah because we felt so what he came do
that big bright scene 14 was a character
that existed in Scripture only like the
only thing that we had ever seen of
saint-14 was his helmet and up until
more recently like the shotgun was a was
a thing and then season season of dawn
which again as that we stated earlier on
it's a season it's not a deal see by any
means necessary and it was one of the
better seasons because narratively
speaking you are bringing a character
back to life that's more that's law bro
hey that's a more think about last wish
rate I remember like dude as a warlock
as a void lock right your voice I'll
think about how we always love almond
Cara that helmet we've had that helmet
for the longest right I didn't know what
it was I didn't what it tied to you
eventually learned out about about
dragons whatever and then last wish rain
comes and you get our first almond car
like these are moments bro like that
connects cuz you're like no I had that
exact 51 I always wanted to know what it
was and now we're actually fighting the
last living I'm a fire like they just
sitting on stuff and I'm with you I
think you know the story with the are
back to iron banner with our salad and
stuff there's so much Lou - salute -
what're wolves right now right here
supposedly it was ollie
so yeah I just think is so cool there's
so much they could do narrative Lee it
even give it a mini piece like I'm with
you man it should be more than just
relegated to just a control thing yeah
and and should have a little bit more to
it besides just yeah yeah wait would you
a mm-hm
yeah I mean I can't agree enough from
what you guys are saying because we've
got as you said you've got what eight
iron Lords that we got to see in
cinematics couple that we laid with
effort eat
know what's up with effort eat some but
life probably knows where she's at or do
I think those yeah but yeah it's like
game I know people like through Fitz
when they change that why is it not
control I honestly would be very curious
now if you would have a different tone
because all we've had is control for so
long if you people would be like yeah
try something different yeah I mean I
would love for them to introduce RIF but
as you're saying it's like so when
you're saying if it's it's own thing is
it's just a permanent note on the
director and Saladin's just chilling
there you want him know when I when I
say like it's own thing and I'm good I'm
using this just as a comparison but chat
don't freak out I'm saying its own thing
like if we compare it to gambit like
gambit it's it's own play mode like it's
its own pool oh yeah anything like have
iron banner be like some sort of like
I'm like I don't say gladiatorial cuz
it's like it's like it's not the right
comparison but you know you you when you
think of the iron Lords you think of
like that like the Dark Ages of where
like they used to kind of like watch
over and rain so you know have some sort
of you know it's again it's got to be
some sort of objective like Pete like
PvP thing cuz it ultimately like [ __ ]
was crazy back wouldn't the iron more
alluring oh you know what I mean and was
Adam shrieks all right and I I mean at
least that's what I would love to say I
would love to see something just
completely refreshed to kind of like
embrace that you know beam of like the
iron Lords instead of it being control
with a Saladin's voiceover I feel you
know that maybe maybe a PvE component in
conjunction when it comes around
possibly I mean you know like I've
always had in like this idea of like
having iron banner as kind of like
in arena mm where you are you're like
almost like a type of like archons Forge
type of deal okay but you can throw in
you know opponents in there as well you
talking my language
I'm all for this all this Spartacus
gladiator yeah all that in like a lot of
that armor um like at least in destiny
one you know it gives off that vibe
remember the furnace piece is the fire
man with the best one of its golden and
I've been talk that talk I never sent in
so I would love to see iron banner in
vault evolved into something like that
where it's more arena base more
gladiatorial or you know again like they
have a mechanic in the game that they
have not used which is the the iron Lord
a battle axe from archons Forge mm-hmm
king of the hill with that thing hmm
like a true you know different moments
to like like true Guardian testing
because isn't it an extension is his
version of the crews words it's an
extension of what guardians should be
doing yeah stuff like that there's so
much man I'm your defense they've done a
good job with say building you know you
know Osiris it matters dramatically
right so yeah he needs that as well and
it is so much there man yeah so much man
I agree
I completely
hmm don't read panco hate that club he's
so disrespectful do it you so disrespect
damnit new rave be nice and I guess this
kind of wraps up what we've talked about
for weeks now is I mean we get to iron
banner weapons kind of reskin couple new
perks not late I mean you think of the
weapons we'd have in the years of iron
banner for destiny one but they had
Activision behind them they had a couple
different studios they worked with one
we can win in dusty too and now that
they're really on their own we start I
guess well we will continue to see how
much we can ask of them given between
what we get in the fall it's like I
would love like hey they bring back rift
we get an entire new set I mean how many
times we've been getting to say how many
times I've had criminally sagger as a
hand cannon problem little three years
horrible it's been hard let's call it
way is but I been just hasn't gotten any
love it's just it's really easy I
remember like you you would you would
log in and you know there's a there's a
weapon pool that should get you Donna
nerwin Mercy's data clever dragon be
like every week that you get that
introduction of something we have been
getting remixed weapons and so we've
been getting the same or Behcet's let's
keep it a punk just cuz oh we got an
ornament slot now no I could put a mod
in there now like it's nothing new drop
it it's just been remix after the remix
and I'm just like yeah I bet you it
definitely needs an overhaul it doesn't
it's not an it's not a highly
anticipated activity as it used to be
and it's just literally a pinnacle drop
activity that's all in it now this for
something that comes around three times
during the season some rise time exactly
for as frequent as it comes it
definitely it needs love I'm completely
with job yeah we don't even have it on
the calendar anymore because they don't
even see well no but that's I know
they're trying to give less away on the
calendars for what's coming in the
season with a checkered shirt but that's
also I wonder if that's them also trying
to downplay it as well yeah because me
again this is where you got to wonder
it's like how much can they do is there
a thing cool coming in the fall
we're asking a lot of the fall but like
we have been staring at this stuff for
three years now so it's it's time I'm
with you I'm with you I mean listen in
my last point on it I live a long I
understand resources you know saying I
really do and I try to be empathetic
towards that and to be honest the reason
why I've given them a pass on it this
season is because I'm gonna be real I
didn't think we would get no dungeon I
didn't I was shocked that we got
prophecy I'll be honest you know say so
for me I look at that
that's resources that's that's
allocating you know to it to a team now
yes granted I know it's supposed to be
going away it's not that this one's not
staying you know hopefully they'll
explain why coming back later for what
coming back later right now so you know
I think it's it's really cool that they
gave us that you know I'm definitely
gonna be jumping in I you know I still
think there's a chance that we get you
know some reprise you know what I think
that Iron Man thing happens is we're
gonna have to revisit a season where he
is the focus and the iron rods are the
focus again and I think it's time and
I'm saying I think it's time we've had a
lot going on in the lore but I think
it's time that they can get like a you
know a season at or whatever that
involves something going on with the
iron Lords and then we can get some
story beats with that it's gonna be
interesting considering we kind of have
a light guide as to what the next couple
of years of destiny is going to look
like with like you know the age of
Darkness now coming into play and
Sabbath soon you know yeah in the in the
system and making her presence and lot
known a lot more now so absolutely mhmmm
house we got you I mean that kind of
covers everything look out for the week
I mean it's a quiet week we got actually
have Titan coming next week but I mean
that was basically we like moments of
triumph starting next week and that has
it and we Koken of really is it I forgot
it was next week yeah I was like I was I
remember because I know so many heroes
is coming later Wow motive trend starts
next next week say not talk about that
not even since dude it's not even know
it's not in the blog it wasn't the
message when when I logged in
month of trowel July seventh is I mean
that's he's right that's almost three
months long so I mean that's you trying
to check every box for how I mean that's
gonna be go make sure you get your every
other Kodu scourge go do Leviathan
that's gonna be you check every box for
the past thirty years so they're gonna
give you as long as possible because
normally most doesn't even jump in this
early like they they shorten some of
those maybe the last six weeks or
whenever it's been it's usually shorter
every time
yeah but how could they that was right
like how could they introduce it without
talking about there's there is no
mention of like what we run with it or
like the armor which typically you know
we kind of hear about that like a week
before it started before so I can start
finding that - that up I've been it up
no yeah we haven't no like unless yeah
unless like in heaven saying yeah in
chat that uh until announce it on bungee
day but uh that's weird
it's reset today things gonna go live
like what is it now or before here yeah
here's all your information an hour
before things are alive and then because
they're prepping everything for the
patch that day cuz we're gonna get one
there but again I think I wonder moments
of triumph cuz there's new tribes new
seals
mm-hmm so I know obviously one doesn't
say it
oh it sorry I think appears yes so yes
the armor and that's a month later so we
got the armor new glowing legendary
armor for solstice looks kind of sick
mm-hmm but moments of triumph I wonder
if it truly is like here's your check
boxes for the year and that's there
isn't as much to hype about it I'll be
kind of curious if that's yeah why I
ain't talking about it yeah no starting
that soon I didn't catch a new solstice
was a little later and it's solstice is
about a month but this is literally July
twenty seconds to launch of Bianca
kisses remember what what everything
else is for last moment but Ryan I don't
remember how minutes what would we get
the burgundy shirt for that one cuz I
think we've both worn it at this point
oh that's the joint way okay you asked
to join what we we get our credit ran
all this that we did this is really
getting did you play around didn't they
introduced the eaz with the last one
that was solstice that was solstice cuz
I hope that comes back the underrated
material dude yeah I liked it they
really have taken simple Nike you
imagine like a 12 e 12 like on the eaz
dude that'd be fantastic
that'd be so good I think that was we
had this discussion last time - that
would require either next-gen or
different engine cos 6012 v12 might
break destiny if you got 60 like 10 nova
bombs flying back and forth to each
other
you might just shut down a PS PS or just
use all that calculation it's just like
shut it shut yeah I did get to
experience it yeah it'll come back I
have to get a comeback I think hopefully
we don't screw the armor up like cuz I
mean what was it the the army you grind
it for wasn't even the one you caught
wasn't even that great a stats and stuff
it was just like I still have it that
grind hurts like I go through all that
and it wasn't worth much anyway I mean
they brought a few woman and you
couldn't even put on one of the seasonal
mods in it yeah yeah and this in the
armor 2.0 version and it had a very
mediocre sterols terrible snap rolls
yeah I got them too it's a free beat
it's like they're like but it's your
free set I'm like dude I grinded my butt
off for that one okay that said they
made us grind I got it for all three
because I wanted the ship which I still
have on my hunter which not a lot of
people probably have because it was
unique and I knew not a lot of people
are gonna have of them man that was
rough like I even had to go pretty hard
towards the end to master working it
took a lot so yeah yeah master where I
got my flames ma'am I don't blame you
looking sick well I was like we've kept
you for a while so I don't to keep you
too long I've got a respect your time so
you're like dude I can talk for all
night long and we know believe me we can
talk forever but we like to respect your
time too so probably can work on
wrapping this thing up next week at
least we'll see to things apparently
tighten and moments so we'll definitely
more to talk about next week but man
dude I'm glad we got you on like it's
been a long long long time in the making
so I know I had a really good time
with you guys tonight I was such a blast
likewise brother always a pleasure
always a pleasure yeah mmm mmm hmm hmm
I'm gonna ask chat real quick we got a
couple people to raid actually when we
wrap this thing up we was gonna do a
little wrap up first but we got gammit
rap artists mid miss noodle another
awesome artist and Aries who's playing
right now as well so got a couple people
have to sing to you guys through here in
a second so if you got any idea of those
three got a very own Aries mod and a
couple others mm-hmm but yeah but before
we go now just for all the people who
want to find you whether it's your
awesome pictures your you know your new
music production you're gonna be putting
out some awesome new dropping some new
singles out there let everybody know
where they can find you what what they
can look for from you anything you got
coming in the future this is your time
oh yeah I mean so with a limited time
that I have a nowadays basically
anything that I post is going to be over
on my Twitter which is a you know just
twitter.com slash and in place as
usually post like most of my my gaming
clips or sometimes spicy takes
definitely if you're a fan of like
screenshots and stuff like that I do
have a public folder on my bio with a
bunch of like 2k resolutions screenshots
that you can use for like wallpapers
stream backgrounds whatever you want I
usually try to update it every season
with new stuff so you know you can keep
an eye out on that I think I depending
I'm not sure when this is gonna happen
but I will be on another podcast
if you guys wanna you know tune it's a
development yeah we still had two reps
in developing yeah I'm not sure when but
I am it's safe to say I'm sure you guys
have heard of it it's a fire team chat
so from IgM you know keep your eyes
peeled for that they asked me on for an
episode five oh that's dull definitely
make sure you go fight in that episode
blow it up for this man because yeah
we're fans a fire team chat we've met
best in it in a couple of those guys
that's all such a cool dude
yeah so lay down so that's that and
probably what I got going on in the near
future or so well that's freaking
fantastic that's five bro let me tell
you the two most prized as a definitely
fair the two pros proudest things I
would be probably be is DCP deep the
little picture you guys got your little
fiction vote for you yes it if I did you
know that that's awesome right that you
you've been a big both that you'd be
kind of cool you you'd be of both both
jerseys it's really cool
I am definitely check out for you on
that big time that's awesome
what about you cutting you know what do
you got coming up this weekend every
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern is the Lord hey
so um yeah we will have Bob boy hustle
and motivate he will be in the building
big Sony guys so we're gonna talk about
what's going on with that we'll talk
about a lot of next gen console stuff
game prices going up
that is definitely a home big right now
I mean because God knows that could be
more expensive some people some people
people are really just heard the n64 was
$80 talk to me talk I'm like score net
like everything's had inflation
excessive games lay except games he's
long and people are makin like I mean
picture something I just got done
playing The Last of Us
that game cost a hell of a lot more than
$60 no question in rural mind I know I'm
with you but there has been pushback
there's some people in my community who
eating it you know they're just you know
very anti and it's gonna be a good
discussion on that we'll talk about the
time I'll carve so much to end on yeah I
agree but we'll see you know you can
swing that flag for me so I'll pass the
old we got that Oh
because I remember to Muhammad Allah I
really play like I had an Al's for
Street Fighter 2 that's where I come
from you know I'm saying so I'm used to
those prices and again that price point
being at $60 for such a long time you
know and now next-gen kind of hinting
hey it's gonna be a little higher so
please check out for that um definitely
oh you had showy here comes the subs
they have redeemed some sit-ups I see
some things it's exercise time with
y'all y'all know how we do let's get
ready
it's Co vid time we gotta work off the
cold fed pounds names what we do here
you know so now as you can see he is in
perfect form this is it here we go
sit-ups are it look look at that correct
form look at the posture look at the
elbows hitting the knee this is premium
content yard this is what you get here
the last word we keep you fit during the
pandemic well Manny got you covered
anytime you want that's all you got is
just always we got we anything cause I
never requested better put them in now
consider this green screen with that
I'll try to help y'all out man you got
to test it I suppose salute to y'all
forget my man eat of work he's got it
pop it right now that's as far as I got
as far as I got yl Peter Sunde 1:00 p.m.
Eastern law Cognito on Twitter and of
course again thank you for support Lords
of gaming dotnet we really appreciate
the support man big time and of course
my boy if you're into statues if you're
into comic books or stuff like that
please check out my boy King David he
has king of the statues tremendous piece
we love it and of course once again
saluting them for coming through the
last word you can't fire always fun
fellow warlike so it was always gonna be
love
so it is what it is but uh eat what you
got going on man
for meee so let's see between now and
next podcast so I'm gonna be on farmers
revenge podcast Thursday night that's
Thursday the 9th podcast that'll be kind
of around the same time as this one so
check out there's I'll tweet where I'm
gonna be probably gonna be working on
prophecy so low potentially this weekend
nice just yeah so low fall I soloed the
cube room mmm
Jesus you're obese so that was the
random funny story I was with my brother
he had to like he's like hey I gotta go
pick something up for my wife and I was
like and we're going through and it's
like hey we got the checkpoint cool and
I'm sitting there I'm like yeah I'll
work on it and then it just starts like
coming together and like two runs later
I'm like he comes back he's like you're
done it was like yeah I got that part
knocked out savage I give you credit
with Fame so that's I got the cube room
which is the one kind of like there's
always one bonkers room in every dungeon
and I mostly like that was wrong cause
died way too much and again you can have
some crappy rng I what's the fallout try
it today you can have some crap rng in
that room by like I figured out where
you like kind of got to be on your game
and where you can completely slow it
down and like wait take your time yeah
and kind of manage it and like the fact
that I got that one the other hard
part's gonna be leading into the boss
yeah like the triangle room to go to the
boss but I will say do not underestimate
xenophanes in that entire dungeon
Osito face yeah the Knights three shots
of the snipers up top single Nani no
phage mountaintop and gnawing hunger is
probably what I'm gonna use for almost
the whole damn run yes you know Zeno's
definitely beast in that I guess where I
worried for you is the triangle room
where the boss boss wanna rebuff step
that way did you got a takeaway here
with his positioning from one of them so
that you could actually eyes on all
three and then see a one if it's
basically starting with your the one
maybe clear wearing then you wanna get
that part is hard I'll be I'll give you
credit but I mean
that's a potentially something I'm gonna
work I've sold flawless the other two so
I got to do it and it's booked before
you do all that I've got my outbreak for
fact it's all requested I'm putting in
today I know and I Nev I can't list so
II be - we don't soul and stuff this is
my formal request I'd be dead chef's
gonna need like a report card afterwards
all right yeah did you knock it out did
you get it done how did he know put a
little pressure I need it bad I'm so
worried it's gonna go away I beat that
catalyst I believe my Danites to be
strong I want this thing but I'll Plus
you know what it is they got the I
bought the ornament the Osiris ornament
that makes I'll bring perfected all gold
I need this Eve I need this so when you
take a little prophecy bang don't forget
me man this weekend highlight your porno
I believe me I can only do that so long
at some point if you get some bad runs I
got I'll go solo friendless I would have
done with everyone I got to do a solo
run first if I get through each
encounter by itself then it's putting
one together but I can't tell you like
chamber of suffering and pit yeah when I
made it through that and died literally
falling down the next section on my firt
one of my like third or four so that is
like the dumbest death I've had so I'm
waiting for the ribbons to screw me
again but we'll see
by the way so why as I've solid flaw no
I soloed I didn't do it flawlessly but I
soloed shattered thrown um and my soloed
pit of haddock heresy
mmm but but mm-hm didn't count it
because unlike shattered throne where
you can leave you can type it
you cannot leave pit and I learned that
the hard way I did too
I have not gone back to do it so I ran
out of great banners right before so Mac
and I was like okay let me go get some
come back and knock this out like a
solid like two and a half hours trying
to lay takedowns olmec and I spent an
ungodly amount of time in the chamber of
suffering yeah that's painful and then
when I finished it and I didn't get the
triumph I was like oh I don't wish that
on nobody asked me what just happened
yeah better and then I learned that you
can't do that so I haven't done it since
[Laughter]
its rough but I still load it as a void
Walker so I was pretty nice maybe I go
yeah you ran bottom tree for it I ran
bottom straight water yeah there's a
hell yeah exactly yeah
yeah there was no enjoy don't shout the
Aries though I have fallen back in love
with
Karnstein are millets oh let me tell you
that synergize is so whelmed we do a
little void lock keep keep quiet for a
second Oh probe Oh
if you run that with devourer right
because um you got to get help
it basically it's by staying alive build
yeah we got do it just slap somebody and
then you get a constant regeneration
like if you get hit it goes back up it
goes back up so you run that would
devour and Umbro you could stay alive
you don't have to necessarily crutch on
well of radiant solar all the time with
your boy built I'm telling you man I was
watching air you don't run to Ares if
he's at the chat I watching him solo on
what you call he
run in armlets during a cut out of this
section of the prophecy rate and I'm
telling that keeps you alive man it
really does that's a really I completely
forgot about Karnstein so like what I
used and this might surprise you a
little bit mm-hmm I ran at the time
obviously izanagi for for the Knights um
cause Optive as my energy the the hand
cannon from a season of undying mm and
hammerhead for the for the boomers of
course um but my exotic exotic was
verities brow really yeah that's because
when that gives you grenade energy what
does it do again I forget it's great
it's a grenade energy on energy weapon
kills yes yes so that's what that's why
I ran the hand cannon as my energy
weapon and I ran the operative just
because like there was more coming at me
right and it was it was a little bit
faster so it because the the one that I
had was kill clip and outlaw mm-hmm I
was constantly getting a damage buff
constantly getting my devourer up nice
and if I missed one I was just consuming
to the grenade because I constantly had
that region name and come in yeah cuz it
synergizes well with like cuz as if it
is you get grenade energy back when you
kill us is our active oh you get if you
just stack that up with verities bro
it's like it always have a grenade
grenade yeah I get it now and that's
dust of our that's the heal I get you
that's how I managed to get through that
one nice apparently meant for like
bashing my head against the wall for an
entire weekend so there's that's that's
what I get to look forward to on my 4th
of July weekend so oh good oh good well
no no it's I do it to myself
I mean I've played since blood-borne
came out I mean I played OG Megaman 2
and 3 uh-huh so painful games are part
of be growing up and just persistence to
get through it I hadn't played a souls
until blood-borne came out and then that
has hooked me on a play to every single
one like mortal soul I've seen that beta
coming out and still way to get my hands
on that but yeah we got what shot
like the demon souls remake all dude I
can't freakin wait for those so yeah
really painful stuff apparently is like
I must what does it say this would be
the right term masochist is messiness to
you yeah
say this is the one doing it to you so
yeah so masochist
apparently so I don't know but it's just
it's the fun challenge because now that
I've run it more a couple times I'm
getting more comfortable when you when I
feel I can actually like when I got to
the point where I made my whisperer
guide or anything when I know it that
well I love that feeling of like right
here here nailed yeah over here go go go
like wouldn't you get to that level I
love that feeling of that understanding
it that well oh yeah I also like the PvE
stuff like PvP I'm okay but when pde
stuff like when it clicks man I love
being like that skilled and being able
to like take anybody throw it too so
yeah dude blood-borne you mentioned
blood-borne and I don't say this lightly
about the king of video game ever but if
I could erase a game from serious
perience it all over again a hundred
percent it would be blood-borne without
skipping a beat nice that's a damn good
choice there's that's my first if that's
what set me it was my first - yeah yeah
person in Dark Souls 3 yep Wow yeah both
of those and then fall in order I've
played both Neos I just finished neo -
not that long ago which is really good
love those like that could it's one of
those when it's programmed well like if
you screw up it's your fault
that's y-you like people who can go
through a flawless entire game run and
you're like alright if they can do that
and I've got full armor on and they're
running around with like a loincloth and
doing this stuff probably on me that
literally how I be like I had to beat
the pontiff pontiff Sullivan mmm on in
Dark Souls 3 bro like I have to get
every like buff like available to me so
like the trick that I came to learn
about the pontiff is you can force him
into doing a specific attack so for the
first half of his health you can force
him to do this lunge
that if you learn properly you can parry
it every time in order to do that is
with the moment the fight starts you run
towards Pontiff get that first parry
that is important you get that first
parry
and then you just keep running you gotta
get distance from it because that will
reset it resets his attack pattern so if
you come back to him he's gonna do that
same exact night attack that allows you
to parry him so with four Perry's you're
able to get them down to like slightly
under half health which there is face to
and oh my god it's just that's the
sensation so when you can like a kill a
boss that's been kicking your ass for
like days and Holmes is so good so the
final fight and suck your o3 or for face
I think it's a three phase fight god
that's long that gave and that's kind of
thing if people picked up SEC euro for
the first time versus so used to playing
a Dark Souls or a blood-borne dodging
technique learning to have to break
myself to learn to parry that was one of
the hardest things but when it finally
got there it was really cool so mm-hmm
alright we're gonna get off a plane
shouldn't talk for another about this
yeah so every time we wrapped up a
podcast I'm always gonna kind of give
like the outro info and then we're gonna
say it has been and then all together we
try and say the last word so I'm not
gonna say it first I wait on you guys
cuz I try and match it but editing later
I can fix it so you guys have been
awesome we're gonna go raid Ares watch
this man play trials he's damn good so
enjoy Holly mod but thank you guys
hanging out episode 110 Thank You NIM
plays it has been a pleasure having you
here don't end your recording see out by
the way just FYI keep those going but
yeah seriously it's been a pleasure glad
we made it happen time and everything
we're gonna let Cognito go to sleep so
for this episode
July 3rd 110 it has been the last word